WELL, I'M GOING TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PATIENCE. WE
HAVE FINALLY, GOTTEN THE AUTHOR
HERE. SO WE'RE GOING TO START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE NEXT
SECONDS. JUST A LITTLE
HOUSEKEEPING INFORMATION, THIS
IS OUR FOURTH HEARING, FOR
ASSEMBLY BILLS. THERE ARE 16
BILLS ON THE AGENDA, TWO HAVE
BEEN PULLED BY AUTHORS OR AUTHOR
PULLS. FILE ªM TWO,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZUBIATE AND FILE
ITEM 15 AB 3247 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN. I SEE WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO HERE AND
SHE'S READY. SO WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND YOU'RE DOING
FILE ITEM SEVEN. 1912. OKAY.
WHEN YOU'RE READY, YOU MAY BEGIN
.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I AM
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
1912, AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THE SKYROCKETING COSTS OF GOODS
AND SERVICES WITH LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS DISPROPORTIONATELY
BURDENED. FOR EXAMPLE, IN SAN
DIEGO, GAS AND ELECTRIC SERVICES
TERRITORY ABOUT 23% OF AVERAGE
RATES ARE ATTRIBUTED TO
LEGISLATIVE MANDATED COSTS. 5%
OF THAT IS ASSOCIATED WITH
PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAMS SUCH AS
NET ENERGY METERING, WHICH
CREATES AN ADDED COST TO PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE SOLAR IN THEIR
HOMES. WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS PROPOSING NEW PROGRAMS
AND REQUIREMENTS, WE SHOULD LOOK
AT HOW EXISTING PROGRAMS MAY BE
LEVERAGED RATHER THAN DUPLICATED
, AND CONSIDER THE COSTS OF NEW
PROGRAMS TO REDUCE THE RATE
IMPACTS. AB 1912 WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, DIRECTS
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE TO
PREPARE A WRITTEN ANALYSIS THAT
INCLUDES RELEVANT DATA ON THE
EFFICACY, COST, IMPACT, AND
OVERALL EFFECT OF EACH PROPOSED
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE PRIOR TO A
VOTE IN LEGISLATIVE POLICY
COMMITTEES. THIS MEASURE IS
MODELED AFTER THE EXISTING
PROCESS OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEES REVIEW OF NEW BILLS
THAT THAT IF THAT AFFECT HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY, KNOWN AS
GRAVERT AB 1912, WILL PROVIDE
LEGISLATORS WITH THIRD PARTY
DETAILED TECHNICAL AND ACADEMIC
DATA ABOUT PROPOSED LEGISLATION
THAT WILL RESULT IN RATE OR BILL
INCREASES ON ELECTRICAL OR
NATURAL GAS BILLS. LEGISLATORS
WILL BE ABLE TO USE THIS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IN TO
SHAPE ENERGY POLICY THAT BOTH
ACCELERATES THE STATE TOWARD
MEETING THE CLIMATE GOALS AND
KEEPS ELECTRIC RATES AFFORDABLE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES IOUS TO PAY
FOR THIS REPORT, AND
SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT LARGE
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS SHALL
NOT RECOVER THE COST FROM ITS
RATEPAYERS. WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS LOURDES AYON, THE
MANAGER OF STATE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS, RELATIONS FOR SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. LOURDES, ALONG WITH SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC, GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE. WANT TO SAY
THAT PROUDLY COMING OUT HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL, AB 1912 I
THINK IS GOING TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION AND
BACKGROUND FOR LEGISLATORS TO
KNOW BEYOND WHAT THE COST IS
GOING TO BE OF A PARTICULAR RATE
OR A PARTICULAR MEASURE THAT IS
PASSED WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE,
AND YOU'LL KNOW WHAT THE COST
WILL BE BEYOND WHAT IT'S GOING
TO COST THE STATE. BUT YOU WILL
ALSO KNOW WHAT IT'S GOING TO
COST RATEPAYERS. AT THE END OF
THE DAY, I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE AN IMPORTANT TOOL, SO THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS. THANK YOU.
NO, NO JOKES TODAY. THANK YOU
SIR. ANY MORE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME FORWARD. AT
THIS POINT, HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THERE ARE NONE. I'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS? SENATOR
EGGMAN? THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING, ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SO WHO
WHO INITIATES THE REVIEW? WOULD
IT BE THE WHO WOULD WHO WOULD DO
THAT? SO I'LL HAND IT OVER TO MY
WITNESS. YEAH. THANK YOU. SO THE
REVIEW WOULD START, WHEN IT IT'S
UPON THE CHAIR. SO THE CHAIR
WOULD REVIEW THE BILLS THAT COME
IN AND THEN THEY WOULD GO OUT TO
THE APPROPRIATE THIRD PARTY,
ENTITY IN THIS CASE, IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S A PUBLIC PUBLIC
ADVOCATES. AND SO IT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO THE PROCESS THAT
EXISTS NOW WITHIN HEALTH
COMMITTEE. WHEN THE BILL COMES
IN, THERE'S A TIMELINE
ASSOCIATED WITH EACH, WITH EACH
MEASURE AND THE THAT OFFICE,
WHEN THEY PRESENT THE BILL IS
GIVEN ENOUGH TIME TO PROVIDE
THAT BILL OVER TO, TO THE THIRD
PARTY REVIEW ENTITY LIKE THAT
UBER, REVIEW THAT IS VERY
SIMILAR TO THAT. YES. OKAY. AND
IT'S AND THE FUNDING WILL COME
FROM THE IOUS. OKAY NOT THE
RATEPAYERS. OKAY. THANK YOU.
VICE CHAIR DALI. SO QUESTION
NUMBER ONE IS WHY IS IT ONLY THE
IOUS AND NOT LIKE CCAS AND THOSE
OTHER ENTITIES THAT PROVIDE,
ELECTRICITY FOR CUSTOMERS, THAT
IS A THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION FOR
NOW. I THINK IT'S HARD ENOUGH TO
GET THIS BILL GOING AND TO HAVE
THE IOUS. BE ABLE TO PAY FOR IT.
I THINK, THERE'S A, SOMETHING TO
IMPROVE UPON OR MAYBE ADD ON IN
THE FUTURE. I THINK IT'S GOOD TO
SEE HOW THIS ONE GOES. AND THE
IDEA OF ADDING ADDITIONAL,
ENTITIES THAT PROVIDE ENERGY IS,
IS A GOOD ONE. OKAY. THEN MY
SECOND QUESTION IS I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BECAUSE I
THINK THAT WE DO NEED SOME
OVERSIGHT, BUT I THIS IS A
FRUSTRATION THAT I'VE HAD THE
WHOLE TIME I'VE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE TURN, WHICH
IS SUPPOSED TO LOOK OUT FOR THE
RATEPAYERS. IT'S AT LEAST WHAT I
THOUGHT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO
DO. BUT UNFORTUNATELY SO MANY
TIMES THEY COME IN AND THEY
SUPPORT, YOU KNOW, POLICIES THAT
ARE THAT DRIVE UP RATES, GREEN
ENERGY, THESE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
POLICIES. BUT THEY DON'T LOOK
OUT FOR THE RATEPAYER. THEY
DON'T ASSESS THAT FOR THE
RATEPAYERS. SO THIS IS SEPARATE
FROM TURN. THIS IS WHICH I WHICH
IS UNFORTUNATE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT THE RATEPAYER THEY
SHOULD BE ANALYZING THESE PIECES
OF LEGISLATION AND SAY, HEY,
THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO COST TO
THE RATEPAYER. I AGREE. AND EVEN
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE, I
THINK THAT THERE'S WE DO INDEED
THERE'S ENTITIES IN PLACE THAT
ARE SUPPOSED TO WATCH OUT FOR
OUR RATEPAYERS. WE HAVE PUC, WE
HAVE PAO, WE HAVE TURN. AND
BASED ON THE LAST, AUDIT REPORT
THAT WAS DONE, THERE WERE SOME
SHORTCOMINGS FROM ON THE PUC
PERSPECTIVE, FROM PUC, FROM PAO,
I DON'T RECALL AT THIS MOMENT
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS ANY
SHORTCOMINGS FROM TURN, BUT BUT
I AGREE WITH YOU. BUT BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT IN PLACE, WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN CREATE
SOMETHING IN THE MEANTIME UNTIL
WE CAN HAVE EVERYONE WORK
WORKING COHESIVELY. ALL RIGHT,
WELL, I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL. IT'S BEEN A FRUSTRATION OF
MINE ALL ALONG THAT WE DON'T
HAVE AN ANALYSIS ON LEGISLATION.
AND WHAT IT'S HOW THE IMPACTS
ARE TO THE ACTUAL RATEPAYER,
IT'S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE THE
RATEPAYERS ARE ACTUALLY PAYING
FOR THEM TO DO THEIR JOB. AND, I
MEAN, WE PAY THROUGH OUR RATES
FOR TURN TO DO THAT FOR US.
THAT'S THAT'S THE WHOLE SYSTEM
IS SET UP THAT WAY. BUT WE DON'T
GET THAT INFORMATION. WE GET AND
I'VE POINTED IT OUT MANY TIMES.
SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
BECAUSE IT'S NOT RATEPAYER MONEY
NUMBER ONE. AND I HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET SOME ANSWERS. SO THAT
AND I THINK LEGISLATION WOULD BE
DIFFERENT VOTED ON DIFFERENT
HERE IF WE KNEW THE DIRECT
IMPACT TO THE RATEPAYERS ON SOME
OF THESE PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT COME THROUGH. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE OUTCOME OF
THIS BILL, AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
GET THE FOLKS THAT SHOULD BE
DOING THAT, THAT THE RATEPAYERS
ARE ALREADY PAYING FOR TO DO
THAT. SO THANK YOU. YEAH THANK
YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. AND YOU HAVE ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. YOU'VE
STATED THAT? YES. AND I'LL JUST
READ WHAT THOSE ARE. ASSIGN A
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE TO
CONDUCT THE REQUESTED ASSESSMENT
AT LARGE. NATURAL GAS
CORPORATIONS AND IMPACTS TO
NATURAL GAS UTILITY BILLS,
REQUIRE THE COLLECTION FROM
SHAREHOLDERS TO FUND THE
ASSESSMENT. IS COLLECTED EVENLY
AMONG THE UTILITIES SO THAT EACH
CONTRIBUTES THE SAME AMOUNT. AND
THAT LAST AMENDMENT IS A TWEAK
TO THE AMENDMENT AND THE
ANALYSIS WHEREBY INSTEAD OF
REQUIRING AN APPROPRIATIONS BY
THE LEGISLATURE, THE BILL WILL
DIVIDE THE COST EVENLY AMONG THE
LARGE ELECTRICAL AND GAS
CORPORATIONS. SO THAT'S THE
PURPOSE. WE'RE STILL LACKING A
QUORUM. SO AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME, WE'LL GET A MOTION AND
MOVE THIS MEASURE FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT
UP IS A SIMILAR MEMBER,
PETRIE-NORRIS. YOU'RE DOING
FINAL ITEM FOR GOOD MORNING.
2368. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
SURE. YES I'VE GOT A COUPLE AND
THEN I'M ALSO PRESENTING. YEAH.
FOR ON BEHALF OF, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT, GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR. GOOD MORNING,
MEMBERS, PLEASED TO JOIN YOU
TODAY TO PRESENT AB 2368, A
MEASURE TO IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTRIC SYSTEM RELIABILITY.
WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND REALLY
THANKING COMMITTEE STAFF. AND
YOU, MR. CHAIR, FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS, ON THIS MEASURE,
AS WE ALL REMEMBER IN 2020, THE
LIGHTS WENT OUT IN CALIFORNIA.
IN 2022, THE STATE EXPERIENCED
ANOTHER NEAR MISS WITH AGENCY
STAFF LITERALLY DIALING FOR
GIGAWATTS AND THE GOVERNOR
TEXTING A STATEWIDE PLEA TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS FOR
CONSERVATION, AND IN 2022, TWO
WEEKS BEFORE THE END OF THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION, WE WERE
WARNED OF ANOTHER POTENTIAL
MID-TERM RELIABILITY EMERGENCY
AND FOUND OURSELVES SCRAMBLING
TO REAUTHORIZE THE EXTENSION OF
THE DIABLO CANYON NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT BEYOND 2025. AT EACH OF
THESE MOMENTS, I THINK MANY OF
US FOUND OURSELVES SCRATCHING
OUR HEAD WONDERING, IS THIS
REALLY THE ENERGY POLICY OF THE
WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY? I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST THAT
IT SHOULD NOT BE, AND I WILL,
YOU KNOW, START WITH THE GOOD
NEWS, WHICH IS THAT SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE SINCE THE
LIGHTS WENT OUT IN 2020 WITH
BETTER COORDINATION AND
INTERAGENCY PLANNING PROCESSES
NOW IN PLACE. BUT THE BAD NEWS
AND THE OPPORTUNITY THAT THIS
BILL IS LOOKING TO ADDRESS IS
THAT THERE REMAINS A GAP IN
MID-TERM PLANNING. SO RIGHT NOW,
WE PLAN FOR THE LONG TERM. THE
IRP HAS A TEN YEAR HORIZON, AND
WE ALSO PLAN FOR THE IMMEDIATE
TERM. THE CURRENT RA PROGRAM
LOOKS ONE YEAR OUT, BUT MID-TERM
PLANNING THE 2 TO 5 YEAR OUTLOOK
IS NOT ADEQUATE AND NOT
SUFFICIENTLY ROBUST, SO AB 2368
WILL TAKE A SYSTEMATIC AND
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESS THAT. THE BILL DIRECTS
THE PUC TO REGULARLY CONDUCT
MID-TERM, A MID-TERM ASSESSMENT
LOOKING AT THE 2 TO 5 YEAR
HORIZON, IT ADOPTS THE
TRANSPARENT AND INDUSTRY
STANDARD FOR RESOURCE ADEQUACY,
A 1 IN 10 LOSS OF LOAD
EXPECTATION. AND FURTHER, THE
BILL REQUIRES THE USE OF
CONSISTENT STANDARDS ACROSS RA
AND IRP PROGRAMS. AND I DO WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS COST SAVINGS.
RECOGNIZE THAT THE RA MARKET IS
EXPENSIVE, RIGHT NOW, AND THAT
ANY IMPACT TO THAT MARKET
CERTAINLY RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT
POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO PRICES, BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THE
STATUS QUO IS VERY EXPENSIVE.
EMERGENCY PROCUREMENT IS VERY
EXPENSIVE. KEEPING JUST IN CASE
RESOURCES ONLINE. IN THE CASE OF
EMERGENCY IS VERY EXPENSIVE AND
AS WE'VE ALL SEEN, TRUE GRID
EMERGENCIES ARE VERY, VERY
EXPENSIVE. ONE EVENT CAN COST
THE STATE $2 BILLION. SO WE WANT
TO TAKE A STRATEGIC APPROACH TO
GET THE RA MARKET BACK IN CHECK
AND BRING DOWN PRICES. WE THINK
THAT THAT STRATEGIC APPROACH IS
REFLECTED WITH AB 2368. SO WITH
THAT, PLEASED TO INTRODUCE
CAITLYN ROEDER FROM EDF AND
HEIDI RATS, WHO IS JOINING US
FROM THE CLEAN ENERGY BUYERS
ASSOCIATION. OKAY. YOU EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS HEIDI RATS.
AND I'M DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
MARKET AND POLICY INNOVATION FOR
THE CLEAN ENERGY BUYERS
ASSOCIATION, OR CIBA. CIBA IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 2368, AB
2368 WILL HELP REDUCE RATES.
CIBA IS A BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
OF MORE THAN 400 ENERGY
CUSTOMERS AND PARTNERS THAT ARE
PURSUING MARKET AND POLICY
SOLUTIONS FOR A RELIABLE, CARBON
FREE ENERGY SYSTEM. MANY CIBA
MEMBERS ARE AMONG THE STATE'S
LARGEST ENERGY CUSTOMERS AND
CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. AS SUCH,
OUR MEMBERS HAVE OBSERVED THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS BETTER PLANNING
FOR GRID RELIABILITY AND
RESOURCE ADEQUACY, OR RA, AS OUR
GRID FACES UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES, INCLUDING INTENSE
WEATHER EVENTS MADE MORE
FREQUENT BY THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
SOUND RA PLANNING IS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THERE ARE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES THAT WILL MEET PRESENT
AND FUTURE NEEDS IN ALL
CONDITIONS, EXCEPT FOR THE MOST
EXTREME. ANYTHING LESS PRESENTS
A THREAT TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY, PUBLIC SAFETY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. ALSO, AS RESOURCE
PLANNING AND RATES ARE
INEXTRICABLY LINKED, WE BELIEVE
IMPROVED AND MORE SYSTEMATIC RA
PLANNING WILL RESULT IN DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON RATES BY REDUCING
THE SCARCITY CONDITIONS IN OUR
ENERGY MARKET. CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT RESOURCE PLANNING,
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION,
LACKS TRANSPARENCY. CONNECTION
TO INDUSTRY STANDARD RELIABILITY
METRICS, AND MID-TERM REVIEW AND
CONSISTENCY. THE INABILITY TO
MEET ELECTRICITY DEMAND WITHIN A
SUFFICIENT MARGIN OF ERROR HAS
LED TO COSTLY EMERGENCY
PROCUREMENT OF NEW RESOURCES
THAT COULD BE AVOIDED WITH MORE
THOUGHTFUL PROGRAMS AND SYSTEMS.
SO IN RECENT MONTHS, WE'VE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES ORGANIZATIONS
THAT REPRESENT PUBLIC POWER,
POWER, AND OTHERS TO REFINE
LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE AND GARNER
BROAD SUPPORT. SO JUST TO
REITERATE, SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
AB 2368 WILL DO. IT WILL ALIGN
PLANNING STANDARDS USED ACROSS
CALIFORNIA'S PLANNING PROGRAMS
AND AGENCIES. IT WILL PROVIDE
GREATER VISIBILITY INTO
PROCUREMENT. IT WILL CONNECT THE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROGRAM TO
KAISER'S EXISTING RELIABILITY
OBLIGATIONS. AND FINALLY, IT
WILL ESTABLISH THAT MID-TERM
CHECK IN TO BRIDGE THE ONE YEAR
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PLANNING AND
THE LONGER TERM INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING. THIS
VISIBILITY INTO THE PIPELINE OF
NEW RESOURCES WILL HELP FORESEE
SHORTFALLS BEFORE THEY OCCUR.
FOR THESE REASONS, HE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORTS AB
2368. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. I'M CAITLIN ROEDER
SUTTER WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND. WE'RE PLEASED TO
JOIN THE CLEAN ENERGY BUYERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT OF AB
2368, EDF IS VERY CONCERNED WITH
THE INCREASING RISK TO
CALIFORNIA'S GRID DUE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE, INCLUDING MORE EXTREME
HEAT, MORE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. AT THE SAME TIME, WE
HAVE TO, OF COURSE, INCREASE THE
LOAD ON THE GRID AS WE ELECTRIFY
MORE AND MORE PARTS OF OUR
ECONOMY, LIKE BUILDINGS AND
TRANSPORTATION. BUT CALIFORNIA,
AS ASSEMBLYWOMAN PETRIE-NORRIS
JUST REMINDED US, EXPERIENCED
BLACKOUTS BACK IN 2020 AND HAS
HAD NUMEROUS CLOSE CALLS SINCE
THEN THAT HAS RESULTED IN REALLY
EXPENSIVE EMERGENCY PROCUREMENT,
BUT PROPER PLANNING CAN ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE GREATER
RELIABILITY, LOWER COSTS AND
LESS POLLUTION. THERE'S A CLEAR
NEED TO REFORM THE FRAMEWORK
THAT GOVERNS THE PLANNING AND
PROCUREMENT OF ELECTRIC
GENERATION IN CALIFORNIA, AND
THIS BILL WILL HELP DO THAT BY
PROVIDING UPDATED GUIDANCE TO
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. SPECIFICALLY, THIS
BILL WOULD MODERNIZE THE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROGRAM TO
MEET THE EVOLVING NEEDS OF OUR
GRID AND FOSTER GREATER
ALIGNMENT BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S
SHORT TERM RESOURCE ADEQUACY
REQUIREMENTS AND OUR LONG TERM
GREENHOUSE GAS TARGETS IN THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN. THIS
IS NECESSARY BECAUSE THE CURRENT
LACK OF A MID-TERM RELIABILITY
ASSESSMENT CONTRIBUTED TO THE
CREATION OF THE STRATEGIC
RELIABILITY RESERVE IN THE FIRST
PLACE. THIS RESERVE IN TURN,
RELIES ON NATURAL GAS POWER
PLANTS, AS WELL AS NECESSITATING
THE EXTENSION OF DIABLO CANYON,
BOTH OF WHICH ARE VERY, VERY
EXPENSIVE IF EXISTING
RELIABILITY PROGRAMS WERE
WORKING, WE WOULDN'T NEED THE
TAXPAYER FUNDED RELIABILITY
RESERVE. CALIFORNIA CAN DO
BETTER THAN THE EXPENSIVE AND
POLLUTING STOPGAP MEASURES LIKE
RUNNING DIESEL GENERATORS OR
TURNING ON OLD PEAKER NATURAL
GAS POWER PLANTS. AB 2368 IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
ENSURING GRID RELIABILITY THAT
IS CLEANER AND LESS EXPENSIVE,
SO WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. PLEASE MR.
CHAIRMAN, JOHN WHITE WITH THE
CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN. WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. MARK JOSEPH,
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES AND
THE STATE ASSOCIATION, STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS, IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. ROBIN HINES WITH
MICROSOFT. AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HI. MY NAME IS ELLEN
BRITTINGHAM. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY POWER.
WE'RE THE SECOND LARGEST CA IN
THE STATE. WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION THAT WE'VE PROVIDED
FEEDBACK TO THE AUTHOR IN THE
SPONSOR. JUST WANTED TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR
RAISING, EXCUSE ME, THE ISSUE OF
MID-TERM SUFFICIENCY UNDER THE
CPUC RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROGRAM.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING
THE AMENDMENTS AND WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR. THANKS. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. CHAIRMAN. MY NAME IS DAN
JACOBSEN. ALSO LISTING SUPPORT
FROM THE PRIME DATA CENTERS FROM
GM EQUINOX AND FROM SALESFORCE.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE. OPPOSITION. ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? COME
FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME. ARE
YOU PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. IF NOT, DO WE HAVE A
PRIMARY? GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. NATALIE SEITZMAN WITH
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POWER AUTHORITY. NOT A POSITION,
BUT WHEN WE WHEN THIS BILL WAS
FIRST TAKING SHAPE, WE HAD
CONCERNS ON UNINTENDED IMPACTS
TO PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES
CAUSED BY FURTHER CONSTRAINING
THE RA MARKET. AND WE WORKED
WITH THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS. HOWEVER, THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS APPEAR TO, PERHAPS
UNINTENTIONALLY, UNRAVEL A BIT
OF THAT. SO WE NEED SOME TIME TO
REVIEW THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
MORE CLOSELY. BUT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY INADVERTENTLY PUT
ADDITIONAL STRAIN ON THE ALREADY
CONSTRAINED RA MARKET, WE WILL
HAVE CONCERNS. SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE TO AVOID THOSE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS,
MR. CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS THEO
PIMCO'S, REPRESENTING THE
ALLIANCE FOR RETAIL ENERGY
MARKETS. THIS IS THE DEFINITION
OF WONKY ENERGY POLICY. AND I'M
TOLD I AM NOW A NEUTRAL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. I'D LIKE TO
THANK BOTH THE AUTHOR, THE
AUTHOR, STAFF AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THREADING THIS NEEDLE.
A VERY POSITIVE OUTCOME. OF
COURSE, WE OUGHT TO RESERVE THE
RIGHT AFTER WE SEE THE ACTUAL
LANGUAGE, BUT THIS LOOKS VERY
MUCH LIKE WHAT WE WERE LOOKING
FOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, LEAH BARROWS ON BEHALF
OF ENERGY. AND I JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE BEFORE ME. BIG THANKS
TO COMMITTEE STAFF AND AUTHORS
OFFICE FOR WORKING WITH US, AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO POTENTIALLY
REMOVING OPPOSITION AND GOING
NEUTRAL AFTER WE LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS, GOOD MORNING, VALERIE
CHIRLA OF ALEJO'S PACIFIC GAS
AND ELECTRIC COMPANY. WE HAD A
CONCERNS POSITION BUT ASSOCIATE
WITH PREVIOUS COMMENTS. THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE, AND THE, COALITION,
WITH THE SPONSORS FOR HAVING SO
MANY ROBUST DISCUSSIONS WITH US,
AND WE THINK THIS IS MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION IS PROBABLY
ADDRESSING ALL OF OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANY MORE TWEENERS OR ANY. NO.
SEEING NONE. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS BY COMMITTEE? NO, I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH US AND GETTING
TO A PLACE THAT I THINK WE HAVE
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL LIVE
WITH. AND, WE YOU HAVE ACCEPTED
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I
APPRECIATE THAT, AND I'LL JUST
STATE WHAT THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE.
REPLACE REFERENCE TO MIDTERM
ASSESSMENT WITHIN THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY PROGRAM AND PLACE IN
THE INTEGRATED RESOURCES PLAN.
MAKE CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO
THE ROLE OF CAL ISO SO AS TO
RETAIN THE CPUC. THEREFORE,
STATE AUTHORITY OVER RESOURCE
ADEQUACY AND FINALLY MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS AND
OTHER PROVISIONS OF THE BILL,
INCLUDING REQUIRING THE CPUC TO
DETERMINE WHETHER MITIGATION
MEASURES ARE NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS RATEPAYER COSTS WITHIN
THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY PLAN
PROGRAM. IS THAT CORRECT? YOU.
THANK YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? WELL, THANK YOU AGAIN,
MR. CHAIR, AND TO YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK WITH US ON
THIS BILL, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU AGAIN. WE'RE
LACKING A QUORUM, SO AT THAT
APPROPRIATE TIME, WE WILL DO
THAT. YOU HAVE YOUR NEXT MEASURE
UP AS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB
2672. YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. PLEASED TO JOIN YOU
TODAY TO PRESENT AB 2006 72, A
BILL TO ALLOW PROJECT HOME KEY
SITES TO RECEIVE A DISCOUNT ON
THEIR UTILITY BILLS. AS YOU
KNOW, THE CARE DISCOUNT APPLIES
TO INDIVIDUAL CUSTOMERS AND
APPLIES TO A CUSTOMER METER.
HOWEVER, THESE HOME KEY SITES
ARE OFTEN IN CONVERTED HOTELS OR
MOTELS WHERE THE PROPERTY OWNER,
SUCH AS A PUBLIC HOUSING AGENCY,
MANAGES THE UTILITY BILL. AS
SUCH, THE CARE DISCOUNT DOES NOT
CURRENTLY APPLY EVEN THOUGH THIS
IS A POPULATION THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE. AB 2672
CLARIFIES THAT IN THESE VERY
SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES, THIS
POPULATION CAN BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE CARE DISCOUNT AND WANT TO
ALSO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AND THANK YOU AND
YOUR TEAM FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL. PLEASED TO BE JOINED
TODAY, BY THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
MY NAME IS SEAMUS GARRITY FROM
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION, IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO, THE SAN
DIEGO HOUSING COMMISSION HAS
BEEN AWARDED MORE THAN $105
MILLION IN STATE HOMEKEY FUNDS
SINCE 2020, TOWARDS THE CREATION
OF 608 PERMANENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS, WITH SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THE SAN DIEGO
HOUSING COMMISSION'S HOMEKEY
PROPERTIES INCLUDE MASTER
METERED PROPERTIES SUCH AS
CONVERTED HOTELS AND MOTELS.
MANY OF THEIR HOME Kò
PARTICIPANTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
CARE DISCOUNTS ON THEIR ELECTRIC
AND GAS BILLS IF THEY LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY. AB 2672 WILL
SIMPLY ALLOW THEM TO RECEIVE
THOSE DISCOUNTS WHEN LIVING IN A
COMMISSION OWNED, CONVERTED
HOTEL AS WELL. WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
YOU CAN COME FORWARD, STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. ISRAEL SALAS
WITH SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC.
PROUD TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CHAU MCNEIL
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANKS.
DAN CHAUFFER AVA COMMUNITY
ENERGY, FORMERLY EAST BAY
COMMUNITY ENERGY AND SUPPORT.
HI, ELLEN BRITTINGHAM ON BEHALF
OF SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY POWER IN
SUPPORT. AN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HEARING SEEING NONE.
WHAT ABOUT OPPOSITION? DO WE
HAVE WITNESSES HERE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. NO
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE QUESTIONS BY
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. VICE
CHAIR DALLEY, I JUST WANT TO,
YOU KNOW, WHEN WE GIVE A CREDIT
OR A BREAK ON SOMEBODY'S RATE,
THERE'S A COST SHIFT TO THAT. IT
HAS TO SOMEBODY HAS TO PAY FOR
THAT, AND SO IN THIS CASE IT
WILL BE OTHER RATEPAYERS AT THE
SAME TIME. WE'VE SPENT $20
BILLION IN TAX REVENUE IN
CALIFORNIA TO HELP GET PEOPLE
OFF OUR STREETS AND HOMELESS AND
ACTUALLY, WE'VE INCREASED
HOMELESSNESS IN THE TIME. SO I'M
HAVING A REAL TOUGH TIME WITH
THIS BILL TO ADD ANOTHER CHARGE.
I MEAN, I KNOW THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE TO HELP OUT THE FOLKS
THAT ARE, ON OUR STREETS, BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY, WE KEEP COST
SHIFTING AND THE RATES GO UP FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE. AT THE SAME
TIME, OUR TAXES ARE GOING UP AND
WE'RE PAYING FOR, AND I DON'T
SEE A REAL BANG FOR THE BUCK. SO
WHAT DO YOU WHAT DO YOU WHAT'S
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT? SO TO THE
FIRST QUESTION AROUND WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS A RATEPAYER COST,
THIS BILL DOES NOT EXPAND THE
CARE PROGRAM. THIS POPULATION IS
ALREADY ELIGIBLE FOR CARE AND
WOULD ALREADY BE RECEIVING THAT
DISCOUNT WERE IT NOT FOR THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE LIVING AT A
MASTER METERED PROJECT HOME KEY
SITE. AND I THINK TO THE BROADER
QUESTION, AS YOU NOTED, I THINK
A LOT OF US HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE EFFICACY OF THE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE
SPENT TO COMBAT THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN THE STATE. AUDITOR'S
REPORT FROM APRIL, AS WE ALL SAW
, THE REPORT FOUND THAT THE
STATE WAS DOING A PRETTY
TERRIBLE JOB OF TRACKING THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND EFFICACY OF
THESE PROGRAMS, HOWEVER, ONE
LITTLE BRIGHT SPOT IN THAT WAS
ACTUALLY THAT OUT OF THE FIVE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY REVIEWED,
PROJECT HOMEKEY WAS LIKELY COST
EFFECTIVE, WHICH IN THE CONTEXT
OF THAT AUDIT WAS A RESOUNDING
ACCLAMATION OF SUCCESS, I WOULD
ARGUE. SO I THINK THAT THAT THIS
IS ACTUALLY A PROGRAM THAT HAS
DELIVERED AND IS DELIVERING
RESULTS AND NOT ANY THIS BILL
CERTAINLY WOULD NOT RAISE COSTS
BECAUSE IT'S A POPULATION THAT'S
ALREADY ELIGIBLE FOR THESE
DISCOUNTS. BUT THE OWNER OF THE
SO LET'S SAY CONVERTED HOTEL,
THERE'S ONE METER FOR THE WHOLE
HOTEL. SO THE OWNER ACTUALLY IS
THE PERSON THAT'S GOING TO BE
PAYING THAT BILL OR GETTING THE
RATE REDUCTION. IT'S NOT THE
ACTUAL INDIVIDUAL IN THAT HOME
OR IN THAT ROOM, BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT A METER ON EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THE ROOMS. SO IT LOOKS LIKE
TO ME SO AND THEN THE SECOND
THING THAT GIVES ME KIND OF
THERE'S NO INCENTIVE TO REDUCE
YOUR ENERGY COST IF YOU IF
YOU'RE NOT THE PERSON THAT
ACTUALLY SEES THE BILL. AND SO
THERE'S JUST SOME THINGS I WANT
TO THROW OUT THERE THAT I THINK
ARE INTERESTING ABOUT THIS BILL
IS ONE METER FOR A CONVERTED
HOTEL TO PROJECT ROOMKEY, WHICH
IS THE OWNER, NOT THE NOT THE
ACTUAL PERSON THAT'S IN THE EACH
INDIVIDUAL ROOM IS GOING TO BE
PAYING THAT BILL. CORRECT. AND
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT IN MANY CASES,
THE PROJECT HOME KEY SITES RIGHT
NOW ARE THE BILL IS BEING PAID
BY THE AGENCY RUNNING THE
PROGRAM, ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
WE'VE INTRODUCED THIS MEASURE IS
THAT, IT IS UNCLEAR HOW MUCH
LONGER THAT ARRANGEMENT WILL
CONTINUE. AND MANY OF THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE RUNNING THESE
PROGRAMS ARE TRANSITIONING TO
INDIVIDUAL BILLING. AND SO AS
PART OF THAT, ONE ENSURED THAT
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE RECEIVING THESE BILLS ARE
THEN RECEIVING THE DISCOUNTS
THAT THEY ARE OTHERWISE ENTITLED
TO. OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? ALL RIGHT.
HEARING SEEING NONE, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY.
AND AGAIN, WE HAVE A Dð PASS AS
A MINUTE TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. AND THE
AMENDMENTS ARE JUST CLARIFYING
THE LANGUAGE, INCLUDING DELETING
REFERENCES TO MASTER METER
PROPERTIES, AM I CORRECT? YES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME, WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM, WE'LL MOVE FOR A MOTION
ON THIS MEASURE. AND NOW YOU'RE
PRESENTING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT, AB 551. YOU MAY. YES.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. AND,
PLEASED TO BE STILL JOINING YOU
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 551 ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT, AND ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK AND
PATIENCE ON THIS BILL. AND WE'LL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS AB
551 IS A BILL DONE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO FACILITATE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE CPUC
PROCESS FOR REVIEWING
APPLICATIONS FOR TRANSMISSION
PROJECTS. ESSENTIALLY, ALL
ACTIONS BY THE CPUC ARE EXEMPT
FROM THE YEAR LONG REGULATORY
PROCESS ESTABLISHED IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT,
EXCEPT FOR ANY CHANGES TO THE
CPUC RULES AND PROCEDURES. WHEN
THE CPUC FIRST ADOPTED THEIR PIA
GUIDELINES, THEY MADE THE
DECISION TO INCORPORATE THEM
INTO THEIR RULES AND PROCEDURES.
AB 551 EXPLICITLY EXEMPTS THE
GUIDELINES FROM THE APA.
OTHERWISE, THE CPUC COULD TAKE
UP TO A YEAR TO UPDATE THEM,
FURTHER DELAYING BROADER
REVISIONS TO THE TRANSMISSION.
REVIEW PROCESS. WE ALL KNOW THAT
THE EXISTING TRANSMISSION REVIEW
PROCESS NEEDS TO BE UPDATED.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THOSE CHANGES
TO OCCUR EXPEDITIOUSLY WITHOUT
CHANGING THE UNDERLYING
ENVIRONMENTAL RIGOR OF THE
REVIEW PROCESS. FINALLY THIS
BILL CLARIFIES THAT A DECISION
BY AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
REGARDING APPLICANT PERMIT TO
CONSTRUCT MAY BE FURTHER
APPEALED AND GIVES A TIME
CERTAIN FOR A FINAL DECISION BY
THE CPUC. BUT SIMPLY, AB 551
ALLOWS US TO START MOVING
QUICKLY ON UPDATING OUR
TRANSMISSION REVIEW PROCESS SO
THAT WE CAN GET PROJECTS OFF THE
GROUND AND MEET OUR ENERGY
NEEDS. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IS THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE.
YOU'LL HAVE TWO MINUTES. OKAY.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR BRADFORD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
CHLOE LUKENS, PROGRAM MANAGER AT
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE. I
OVERSEE THE WORK OF STAFF WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUC
TRANSMISSION PROCEEDINGS. AND
THE KAISER TRANSMISSION PLANNING
PROCESS. THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE SUPPORTS AB 551. THE BILL
WILL FACILITATE THE CPUC. S
EFFORTS TO STREAMLINE THE
TRANSMISSION PERMITTING PROCESS
AND WILL HELP NEEDED ELECTRICAL
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS BE
EVALUATED MORE QUICKLY, WHILE
CONTINUING TO UPHOLD THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESSES.
THE CURRENT PERMITTING PROCESS
INVOLVES SEVERAL RULES SET FORTH
IN CPUC S GENERAL ORDER 131 D,
AND THE CPUC S RULES OF PRACTICE
AND PROCEDURES. CURRENTLY, IF
THE CPUC WANTS TO MAKE ANY
CHANGES TO ITS RULES OF PRACTICE
AND PROCEDURES, THOSE CHANGES
MUST BE APPROVED BY THE OFFICE
OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW OR OIL,
WHICH CAN BE A LENGTHY PROCESS.
AB 551 WOULD EXEMPT THE CPUC
FROM HAVING TO SEEK APPROVAL
FROM OIL, SPECIFICALLY ON
CHANGES TO REGULATIONS AND
GUIDELINES REGARDING
TRANSMISSION, PERMITTING AND HOW
IT CONDUCTS ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
CONSISTENT WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT OR
SEQUA. IN ADDITION, THIS BILL
MODIFIES THE CURRENT CPUC
PROCESS INVOLVING PROTESTS OF
TRANSMISSION RELATED PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS
BEING EXEMPT FROM THE PERMITTING
PROCESSES. THE PROJECTS WOULD BE
REVIEWED USING THE CPUC S ADVICE
LETTER PROCESS, AND ANYONE WHO
OBJECTS TO THE PROJECT WOULD BE
ABLE TO APPEAL THE CPUC APPROVAL
OF A TRANSMISSION PROJECT, AFTER
WHICH THE CPUC WOULD HAVE A
SPECIFIED AMOUNT OF TIME TO
CONSIDER THE APPEAL. THE CPUC IS
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING HOW TO
REVISE GENERAL ORDER 131 TO
STREAMLINE THE CPUC PERMITTING
PROCESS. IN A RULEMAKING
PROCEEDING, WHICH HAS GARNERED
BROAD STAKEHOLDER INPUT. SO THIS
BILL IS TIMELY. THIS CONCLUDES
MY TESTIMONY. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. AND WE SUPPORT AB
551. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
COME FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YOU MAY COME FORWARD AT THIS
TIME. GOOD MORNING BRANDON EBCLC
FROM PG AND E. WE ARE REVIEWING
THE BILL THAT RECENTLY CAME INTO
PRINT. WE HAVE HAD PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THE LANGUAGE THAT THE,
AMENDMENTS ARE SUGGESTING TO
CHANGE. ULTIMATELY, WE JUST HAVE
SOME HESITANCY AND SOME CONCERNS
AROUND THE LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS
THE GUIDELINES TO SUPERSEDE A
GENERAL ORDER, AS EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM IS PART OF THE GENERAL
ORDER REFORM. WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN'T
OVERWRITE THAT REFORM WITH A
SIMPLE GUIDELINES. SO APPRECIATE
IT AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TWEENERS ANY OF THAT?
SEEING NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? NO, THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR
PRESENTING THIS. FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT, WE DO HAVE A DO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. AND
AGAIN, I'LL STATE THE AMENDMENT
TO CLARIFY THE EXEMPTION TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT.
PROCESS IS STRICTLY FOR
SUCCESSOR GUIDELINES TO THE
CPUC. GUIDELINES FOR ENERGY
PROJECT APPLICATION REQUIRING
CEQA COMPLIANCE. THAT'S A
MOUTHFUL. AND PRE-FILING AND
PROPONENT ENVIRONMENTAL
ASSESSMENTS IS THAT CORRECT?
CORRECT, CORRECT. ALL RIGHT.
AGAIN, WE'RE LACKING A QUORUM,
BUT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME,
WE'LL SEEK A MOTION. AND, THANK
YOU FOR THIS. THANK YOU. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT, REQUEST AN AYE VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS, YOU GOT IT. ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON. OH. WERE YOU SORRY?
WERE YOU HERE FIRST? I'M SORRY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. I
BASED IT ON ARRIVAL, BUT. SORRY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YES. YOU CAN GO
RIGHT AHEAD. YOU'RE PRESENTING,
LET ME GRAB IT REAL QUICK. AB
2661. YOU MAY, MAY, MAY BEGIN.
GOOD MORNING. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AB 2661 WILL HELP ACHIEVE
CALIFORNIA'S RENEWABLE GOALS BY
LEVERAGING THE EXISTING
CAPABILITIES OF WESTLANDS WATER
DISTRICT TO DELIVER NEW SOLAR
GENERATION AND TRANSMISSION
LINES TO COMBAT THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. CALIFORNIA HAS
SET AMBITIOUS GOALS TO INCREASE
THE USE OF CLEAN ENERGY, AIMING
TO ACHIEVE 60% ELIGIBLE
RENEWABLE ENERGY BY 2030 AND
100% ZERO CARBON ENERGY BY 2045,
I'LL REMIND YOU GUYS, WE'RE ONLY
SIX YEARS AWAY FROM OUR FIRST
GOAL DEADLINE TO MEET THESE
GOALS. NEW RENEWABLE ENERGY
FACILITIES AND THOUSANDS OF
MILES OF NEW TRANSMISSION LINES
ARE NEEDED. THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR HAS
ALREADY IDENTIFIED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP 30,000MW
OF SOLAR IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. CAL, CAL ISIL'S
IDENTIFICATION OF THESE
POTENTIAL RESOURCES IS
ESPECIALLY TIMELY GIVEN CHANGES
OCCURRING IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
DUE TO THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT. AS
GROUNDWATER BASINS ADOPT
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT PLANS, MANY REGIONS
OF THE STATE ARE EXPECTED TO
EXPERIENCE AS MUCH AS 20%
DECLINE IN AVAILABLE WATER
SUPPLY BY 2030. DUE TO THIS
MASSIVE CHANGE, IT IS ESTIMATED
THAT BETWEEN 500,000 AND 900,000
ACRES OF FARMLAND MAY NEED TO BE
FALLOWED IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ALONE, THIS FALLOWED
FARMLAND CAN BE THE KEY TO
EXPANDING OUR SOLAR GENERATION.
WESTLANDS WATER DISTRICT WHO IS
IN THE BEST POSITION TO IDENTIFY
IDENTIFY SUITABLE FALLOWED LAND
IN THEIR SERVICE TERRITORY FOR
CONVERSION TO SOLAR GENERATION
CAN HELP CONTRIBUTE TO THE
STATE'S RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
WHILE MAKING UP FOR LOST WATER
SUPPLY REVENUES NEEDED TO
CONTINUE SERVING THEIR REMAINING
WATER CUSTOMERS. UNFORTUNATELY,
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH TRANSMISSION CURRENTLY
PLANNED IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO
CAPITALIZE ON THIS OPPORTUNITY,
THAT IS WHY AB 2661 WILL GIVE
WESTLANDS WATER AUTHORITY,
WESTLANDS WATER DISTRICT EXCUSE
ME, THE AUTHORITY TO BUILD, OWN
AND OPERATE TRANSMISSION LINES
TO CONNECT THIS NEW GENERATION
TO THE GRID. THIS WILL HELP US
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE GOALS WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROVIDING AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
PLACES LIKE WEST FRESNO COUNTY,
WHERE THE NEED FOR SKILLED AND
WELL-PAYING JOBS IS CRITICAL.
THE COMMUNITIES OF HURON,
MENDOTA, SAN JOAQUIN, FIREBAUGH
AND TRANQUILITY, COULD BE
BENEFICIARIES OF THIS. THE
PROJECTS THAT COULD BE
UNDERTAKEN THROUGH THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL WILL
HELP THESE WORKERS UPSKILL AND
ENTER INTO THE TRADES WHICH WILL
UPLIFT THESE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE OFTEN LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE INVESTMENTS. I WOULD ALSO
JUST LIKE TO SAY ON THE RECORD
THAT THERE ARE ALSO WE ARE ALSO
WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
LIKE THE COUNTY OF FRESNO AND
MANY OF THE CITIES I MENTIONED
IN THIS AREA, TO MAKE SURE THERE
IS A PROCESS IN PLACE FOR
WESTLANDS AND THOSE THEY
CONTRACT WITH TO ENGAGE WITH
LOCAL PARTNERS AND ENSURE THE
SOLAR AND TRANSMISSION PROJECTS
DELIVER THE COMMUNITY BENEFITS
THAT WE TRULY NEED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB 2661 IS MR. MARK JOSEPH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY WORKERS, AS
WELL AS ELIZABETH JOHNSON ON
BEHALF OF WESTLANDS WATER
DISTRICT. YOU EACH WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
TODAY. MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
JOHNSON, AND I'M THE DEPUTY
GENERAL MANAGER FOR WESTLANDS
WATER DISTRICT. WESTLANDS IS A
CALIFORNIA WATER DISTRICT
SERVING 614,000 ACRES IN WESTERN
FRESNO AND KINGS COUNTY. AB 2661
WOULD PROVIDE AUTHORITIES TO
WESTLANDS THAT ARE CRUCIAL FOR
ALLOWING OUR DISTRICT TO
EFFECTIVELY PLAN AND PROVIDE
STRATEGIC OVERSIGHT OF LAND
BEING TRANSITIONED OUT OF
AGRICULTURAL USE TO SOLAR WITHIN
OUR DISTRICT. THE NEED TO
TRANSITION THIS LAND HAS BEEN
DRIVEN BY WATER SUPPLY,
RELIABILITY PROBLEMS IN THE
DELTA OVER THE LAST DECADE. LAND
FOLLOWING HAS VARIED BETWEEN 120
AND 220,000 ACRES. AND NOW, WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT, OUR FARMERS WILL
HAVE LESS GROUNDWATER AVAILABLE,
LEADING TO MORE LAND NEEDING TO
BE FALLOWED. SOLAR DEVELOPMENT
HAS EMERGED AS A LAND
REPURPOSING APPROACH THAT
PROVIDES A PRODUCTIVE USE OF THE
LAND, PROVIDING JOBS AND
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES, WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME HELPING MEET RENEWABLE
ENERGY GOALS. WE HAVE BEGUN A
CEQA PROGRAMMATIC ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS FOR THE LONG TERM, BUT
TEMPORARY CONVERSION OF 130,000
ACRES FOR SOLAR GENERATION, WITH
THE HOPE THAT AT THE END OF THE
PROJECT'S USEFUL LIFE,
APPROXIMATELY 30 YEARS AS
APPROPRIATE, THE LAND CAN BE
RETURNED TO IRRIGATED
AGRICULTURE. OUR OVERSIGHT
PROVIDED THROUGH THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW WESTLANDS TO FAVOR
TRANSITION OF LANDS THAT ARE
MARGINAL DRAINAGE, IMPAIRED, OR
WHICH ARE IDEAL FOR DUAL USES
SUCH AS FLOOD WATER RECHARGE,
AGRIVOLTAICS AND THE LIKE. IT
ALSO ALLOWS US TO MANAGE OUR
LANDS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY PLAN.
THE SURROUNDING USES AND
COMMUNITY NEEDS, AND TO BETTER
PRESERVE THE AGRICULTURAL
HERITAGE OF THE DISTRICT AS IT
MAKES THIS SIGNIFICANT
TRANSITION FOR THE NEXT 30
YEARS. WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAWYER'S LEADERSHIP ON
THIS BILL AND RESPECTFULLY ASKED
FOR THIS COMMITTEE'S APPROVAL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS MARK
JOSEPH ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES,
THE CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL, ÁP
2661, IS AN ELEGANT SOLUTION TO
SEVERAL WELL-KNOWN PROBLEMS. WE
NEED LOTS MORE ELECTRIC
TRANSMISSION TO DELIVER CLEAN
ENERGY. WE HAVE TO CONTROL
ELECTRIC RATES. WE NEED TO FIX
THE MAJOR TRANSMISSION
CONSTRAINT THAT IS FORCING LOTS
OF SOLAR IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TO BE CURTAILED BECAUSE IT CAN'T
REACH NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, WHICH
IS WASTING LOTS OF MONEY. AND WE
NEED TO CREATE INCOME FOR PEOPLE
WHOSE FARMLAND NO LONGER HAS
RELIABLE WATER SUPPLY OR IS
DRAINAGE IMPAIRED. AND FOR THE
PEOPLE WORKING AND LIVING IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES. AND WE NEED
TO DO ALL OF THIS QUICKLY. THIS
BILL ADDRESSES ALL OF THESE
PROBLEMS BY GIVING THE WESTLANDS
WATER DISTRICT THE AUTHORITY TO
BUILD AND OWN TRANSMISSION LINES
IN THE DISTRICT, ALONG WITH
SOLAR AND FOR SALE INTO THE
WHOLESALE MARKET. AS YOUR
ANALYSIS CORRECTLY IDENTIFIES
LOTS OF OTHER TYPES OF DISTRICTS
HAVE SIMILAR AUTHORITY. THIS
BILL WOULD PLUG A GAP IN THE
CODE SO THAT WESTLANDS WATER
DISTRICT CAN PLUG A GAP IN OUR
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM. I WANT TO
STRESS THAT THE BILL DOES NOT
HARDWIRE ANY PARTICULAR OUTCOME.
NOTHING WOULD HAPPEN UNLESS THE
PUC FINDS THAT THIS WOULD BE A
GOOD DEAL FOR RATEPAYERS. THEN
IF AND ONLY IF IT'S COST
EFFECTIVE FOR RATEPAYERS, THE
PUC WOULD SEND THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CAISO AND
THEN IF AND ONLY IF THE CAISO
SELECTS THE PROJECT IN ITS
ANNUAL TRANSMISSION PLAN, THE
PLAN COULD PROCEED. I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE DISTRICT DOES NOT
REPLACE PGE AS THE LOCAL
ELECTRIC SUPPLIER. IT'S NOT
BECOMING A LOCAL RETAIL ELECTRIC
UTILITY. THE BILL PROHIBITS THE
WESTLANDS WATER DISTRICT FROM
SELLING ELECTRICITY AT RETAIL.
IT WOULD JUST SUPPLY GENERATION
AND TRANSMISSION INTO THE
WHOLESALE MARKET. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION. PLEASE
CHAIRMAN BRADFORD AND MEMBERS,
BOB GIROUX, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DAIRY INSTITUTE AND
THE E AND J GALLO FAMILY WINERY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MR.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN WHITE WITH
THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN. WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MR.
CHAIRMAN DANIEL KIM WITH GOLDEN
STATE CLEAN ENERGY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. WHEREAS THE DOC
MARTENS. HE GOT HE GOT CALLED
OUT, HUNTER STERN WITH IBEW
1245. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OSORIO FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS BILL IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. LILY MCKAY, ON BEHALF
OF SAN LUIS DELTA MENDOTA WATER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ALEJANDRO SOLIS, ON BEHALF OF
THE LATINO EQUITY ADVOCACY AND
POLICY INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. DEAN TAYLOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. CODY BOYLES ON BEHALF
OF THE AG ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION, AS WELL AS THE
AMERICAN PISTACHIO ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, MARCUS
DETWILER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
NOW LET'S MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YOU MAY
COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME. OKAY.
I SEE YOU SCARED ALL THE
OPPOSITION AWAY OKAY. GOOD JOB.
THAT'S HOW WE DO IT. THAT'S HOW
WE DO IT. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS?
SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
SO HELP ME UNDERSTAND. IS. AND
SO IT GOES. SO THAT AFTER THE
ASSESSMENT OF LAND AG LAND THAT
NEEDS TO BE FOLLOWED IS THAT
LAND THEN PURCHASED BY WESTLANDS
OR IS IT RENTED FROM THE FROM
THE FARMER? HOW HOW DOES THAT
RELATIONSHIP WORK. SO WESTLANDS,
TO MY KNOWLEDGE AND WESTLANDS,
YOU KNOW THE ASSISTANT GENERAL
MANAGER CAN ANSWER THIS, BUT
THEY ALREADY HAVE, OWNERSHIP OF
CERTAIN LANDS. AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
OTHER LANDS, BUT CURRENTLY
THERE'S ABOUT 130,000 ACRES
ALREADY THAT HAVE BEEN FALLOWED
IN THAT AREA. SO. CORRECT. SO
WESTLANDS WATER DISTRICT'S OWNS
ABOUT 70,000 ACRES OF LAND THAT
WOULD BE COMMITTED TO THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT. VSIP
PROJECT, AND THE REST OF THE
130,000 ACRES ARE UNDER CONTRACT
FOR A LONG TERM LEASE WITH
GOLDEN STATE CLEAN ENERGY. OKAY.
THANK YOU. AND THEN ALL OF THIS
BECAUSE YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW
IT'S GOING TO HELP PEOPLE IN
SMALL RURAL COMMUNITIES. AND IS
THAT BECAUSE OF THE INSTALLATION
OF THE POWER LINES OR HOW WERE
YOU TALKING ABOUT THAT? BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T SELL IT RETAIL. RIGHT.
SO NOBODY'S GETTING. YEAH. SO
WE'RE HAVING CONVERSATIONS. ONE
OF THE ONE OF THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING WITH THE
TRADES IS THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
LOCAL FOLKS THAT POTENTIALLY
COULD GET DISPLACED OUT OF WORK,
THAT WOULD BE TRAINED AND
UPSKILLED TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
SOME OF THESE JOBS. WE KNOW THAT
THE LIFE OF THESE JOBS ARE
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S A TEN
YEAR, I THINK, IN TERMS OF THE
BUILD OUT, IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH
SOLAR WILL BE BUILT IN THAT
AREA, BUT WE'RE ALSO HAVING
OTHER CONVERSATIONS TO SEE WHAT
OTHER COMMUNITY BENEFITS CAN BE
PUT IN PLACE AS A RESULT OF THIS
TYPE OF INVESTMENT GOING INTO
THE COMMUNITY, WE'VE BEEN HAVING
VERY CLOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
OUR LOCAL FOLKS AND ALSO WITH
THE COUNTY, AS WELL AS WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE HERE TODAY
. OKAY. THANK YOU. AND I MEAN, I
WON'T SOUND LIKE A PARANOID
PERSON WHO REPRESENTS THE DELTA
REGION, BUT WESTLANDS IS ALWAYS
THE BLACK HAT IN OUR AREA,
OWNING ALL THE WATER NOW THEY
WANT TO OWN ALL THE WATER AND
ALL THE POWER. MAKES ME NERVOUS.
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS? I LIKE
BLACK CATS. I AM ONE ANYWAY.
OKAY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU, AT THAT TIME, WE'LL
SEEK A MOTION FOR THIS MEASURE.
ALL RIGHT. WHO'S NEXT? IS IT?
MISS. B¢O. BAUER-KAHAN. AYE.
WILK CALDERON WAS HERE, BUT SHE
YIELDED THE LAST TIME YOU'VE
BEEN HERE. ARE YOU READY TO GO?
WE'RE GOING TO LET
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAUER-KAHAN GO
ON. SHE HAS ONE. YEAH, SHE HAS
ONE, BILL. HOW NICE. YEAH YOU'RE
PRESENTING FINAL ITEM EIGHT AB
2054. YES THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR,
AND THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE.
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE FAST. I
THINK WE NOW, THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE, HAVE LITTLE TO NO
OPPOSITION. SO HOPEFULLY THIS
WILL BE QUICK, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS FIRST. I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS. AND I ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS I JUST REFERENCED.
AND THE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S PRIMARY CONCERNS BY
REMOVING THE ALLOCATION OF
OVERSPENT BALANCING ACCOUNT
COSTS BETWEEN SHAREHOLDERS AND
RATEPAYERS AND INSTEAD SUBJECTS
SUCH OVERSPENDING TO ADDITIONAL
REVIEW BY THE CPUC. I THINK IT
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE
BALANCING ACCOUNTS AS A WAY THAT
WE ARE DRIVING UP COSTS ON
RATEPAYERS AND THE ABUSE THAT
MAY BE HAPPENING UNDERNEATH
THEM. BUT IMPORTANTLY, THE
COMMITTEE HAS PUT IN, A LOT OF
EFFORT TO DESIGN LANGUAGE THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THOSE ACCOUNTS. AND
SO I HOPE WE'LL BE BACK IN THE
FUTURE IF WE DO START TO
UNDERSTAND THERE'S ABUSE HERE
THAT IS CAUSING HARM TO
RATEPAYERS TO ADDRESS THIS MORE
BROADLY. BUT WITH ME TODAY, TO
SUPPORT THE BILL, IS SOMEONE
FROM TURN. LET ME SEE WHO WE
HAVE FROM TURN. KATIE MORRIS
MURATSUCHI FROM TURNED. I GET
THAT RIGHT. YEAH. NO ONE GETS
MURATSUCHI RIGHT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS KATIE
MORRISON. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK OR
TURN. TURN HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE
RATEPAYER ADVOCATE AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND AT THE
LEGISLATURE, CHAMPIONING
AFFORDABLE BILLS AND CUSTOMER
PROTECTIONS THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE, CLEAN AND
RELIABLE ENERGY. I AM HERE TODAY
AS SPONSOR OF AB 2054. OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS, INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY CUSTOMER RATES,
CUSTOMERS RATES HAVE DOUBLED TO
MORE TO MORE THAN DOUBLED IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS ALONE. PG AND E
RATES HAVE INCREASED 64. MORE
AND MORE OF THESE INCREASES
REFLECT COSTS TRACKED AND
BALANCING ACCOUNTS. IN A GENERAL
RATE CASE, THE CPUC WILL ADOPT A
FORECAST FOR A UTILITY PROGRAM.
IN SOME CASES, THE CPUC WILL
SIMULTANEOUSLY ADOPT A BALANCING
ACCOUNT FOR TRACKING COSTS OF
THE PROGRAM THAT EXCEEDS THE
COMMISSION'S ALREADY APPROVED
FORECAST, ACCORDING TO THE
AUGUST 2023 STATE AUDITOR
REPORT, ABOUT A THIRD OF IOU
REVENUE IS TRACKED IN THESE
BALANCING ACCOUNTS. AS NOTED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS, THE
DOLLARS EXCEEDING THE AUTHORIZED
FORECAST AND TRACKED IN THESE
ACCOUNTS DO NOT ALWAYS UNDERGO
THE SAME LEVEL OF REVIEW THAT
THE ORIGINAL FORECAST DID. THE
INCREASING RELIANCE ON THESE
BALANCING ACCOUNTS IS CREATING
GREATER RATE UNPREDICTABILITY
AND INCREASED WORKLOAD FOR
RATEPAYER ADVOCATES IN THE CPUC,
BUT MOST OF ALL, HIGHER
ELECTRICITY COSTS FOR CALIFORNIA
CUSTOMERS. AB 2054 WOULD CLARIFY
THAT THE IOUS SHOULD EXPECT THAT
THESE BALANCING ACCOUNTS COULD
BE SUBJECT TO ADDITIONAL REVIEW
BY THE COMMISSION. IT WOULD ALSO
CREATE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT WOULD TRACK THE AMOUNTS
ABOVE THE AUTHORIZED COSTS IN
THE BALANCING ACCOUNTS, AND
SCRUTINIZE IT AND THE SCRUTINY
THAT THESE ACCOUNTS ARE
RECEIVING. THIS INFORMATION
WOULD HELP UNDERSCORE THE
GRAVITY OF THE PROBLEM, AND
INFORM CPUC AND LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION OF BALANCING
ACCOUNTS AND REFORMS OF THESE
ACCOUNTS. MOVING FORWARD. PART
OF ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM OF
BALANCING ACCOUNTS IS
UNDERSTANDING THE MAGNITUDE OF
IT. AB 2054 WILL SHED LIGHT ON
THE PRACTICES CURRENTLY
SURROUNDING THESE ACCOUNTS AND
TURN RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE CANALE, ESTÁ UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT. BRAD HEVNER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT. OKAY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. ISRAEL SALAS
WITH SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS
COMPANY, WITH THE AMENDMENTS
BEING ADOPTED TODAY, WE ARE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION. THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. THANK YOU.
SAME POSITION. CATHERINE BORG
WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
WERE IN OUR OPPOSITION TODAY.
AND THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
US TO RELIEVE OUR CONCERNS.
THANKS BRANDON. YOU BACK PGA
SAME AS THE OTHER. I APPRECIATE
THE STAFF SHARING THE
AMENDMENTS. IT'S VERY HELPFUL TO
SEE THE LANGUAGE. THANK YOU. SO
SORRY I WAS DISTRACTED. MELISSA
ROMERO CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DÍAS. ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS? OKAY. I
JUST WANT TO FOR THE RECORD, I
WILL READ SENATOR BRADFORD'S
BEEN READING THE AMENDMENT, SO
I'LL GO AHEAD AND READ THOSE
AMENDMENTS. SURE THAT YOU ARE
AGREEING TO TAKE I. YES, I TOOK
THEM DELETED LANGUAGE,
REFERENCED REFERENCING
SHAREHOLDERS AS THE CPUC COST
REVIEW NECESSARY TO DETERMINES
WHETHER UTILITY COSTS ARE
RECOVERABLE FROM RATEPAYERS OR
SHAREHOLDERS, NARROWS THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE APPLICATION
OF THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS TO
WILDFIRE MITIGATION CAPITAL COST
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
IN THE ANNUAL REPORTING BY THE
CPUC TO THE LEGISLATURE,
INCLUDING THE STATUS OF
BALANCING ACCOUNTS, ACCOUNTS
WHERE COSTS ARE OVER FORECAST,
THE NUMBER OF REVIEWS THE CPUC
HAS CONDUCTED OF THESE COSTS AND
COST BY THE UTILITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN APPROVED OR DENIED BY THE
CPUC IS THAT CORRECT? I BELIEVE
IF IT'S THE ANALYSIS THAT TOOK
ALMOST AS LONG AS MY
PRESENTATION. ALL RIGHT. WELL,
WE GET THESE AMENDMENTS LATE,
AND I'M GLAD YOU WERE ABLE TO
SHARE THEM. SO YOU'RE WELCOME TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU. A FEW MONTHS
AGO, I GOT A CALL FROM LYNNE,
WHO'S 101, IN MY DISTRICT AND
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY RESPONSIBLE
AND CONTROLLING HER ENERGY USAGE
AND HAS NEVER PAID MORE THAN
$100 FOR HER UTILITY BILL. AND
IT WENT UP TO 300. THAT IS WHAT
IS HAPPENING TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
ACROSS THE STATE, AND I JUST
WANT TO URGE ALL OF US TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PAY
ATTENTION TO CALIFORNIA'S
RATEPAYERS AND DRIVE THEIR RATES
DOWN, BECAUSE THEY ARE HURTING
RIGHT NOW. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. AT THE WHEN WE
GET A QUORUM, WE WILL ENTERTAIN
THAT MOTION. UP NEXT, WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. WE
HAVE TWO BILLS. I BELIEVE. WE'LL
START WITH AB 311. OR DOES THAT
WORK FOR YOU OKAY. PROCEED
PLEASE.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL,
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AB 3111 REQUIRES NEW LARGE
CUSTOMER SITED SOLAR AND STORAGE
PROJECTS TO NOTIFY THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION OF
THE INSTALLATION AND SCOPE OF
THESE PROJECTS. CURRENTLY, THE
CEC HAS TO RELY ON INFORMATION
PROVIDED TO THEM BY CAISO ENERGY
PROVIDERS AND OTHER SOURCES TO
GET A SENSE OF WHAT DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES ARE ON THE
GROUND. THIS BILL STREAMLINES
THE SIX INFORMATION GATHERING BY
HAVING THAT INFORMATION DIRECTLY
PROVIDED TO THEM. THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS OF
DUPLICATIVE REPORTING AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES THE
REPORTING BURDEN ON THE
AGGREGATED DER DEVELOPERS. THIS
BILL IS MEANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
CEC AND THE REST OF THE STATE'S
ENERGY AGENCIES HAVE A COMPLETE
DER DATA SET HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS ALLISON
RAIMI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AND THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY
EMPLOYEES. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
GREAT. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, ALLISON RAIMI HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES,
THIS IS A TURNING POINT IN OUR
STATE'S ELECTRIC INDUSTRY. WE
ARE TRANSFORMING INTO A SYSTEM
WITH HIGH PENETRATION OF
CUSTOMER SITED SOLAR AND
STORAGE. THIS CÁC FORECASTS AN
ADDITIONAL 18,000MW OF CUSTOMER
SOLAR AND 4500MW OF CUSTOMER
STORAGE IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS
ALONE. MICROGRIDS AND VIRTUAL
POWER PLANTS ARE PROLIFERATING,
BUT WHAT EXACTLY IS BEING
INSTALLED? THE CSP HAS
DIFFICULTY ACCURATELY
FORECASTING AND REPORTING THE
IMPACT OF CUSTOMER SITED SOLAR
AND STORAGE IN ITS INTEGRATED
ENERGY POLICY REPORT. THIS MEANS
THAT ALL THE ALL OF THE PLANNING
THAT FLOWS FROM THAT REPORT,
SUCH AS THE PUC S INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING AND RESOURCE
ADEQUACY REQUIREMENTS, IS NOT AS
ACCURATE AS IT NEEDS TO BE. WE
NEED EARLY AND EFFECTIVE
PLANNING AND TRANSPARENCY TO
REACH OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
COST EFFECTIVELY, RELIABLY AND
SAFELY. WE MUST KNOW AT THE
EARLIEST POSSIBLE TIME WHAT THE
FORECAST IS BEING CONSTRUCTED.
AB 3111 SOLVES THIS PROBLEM BY
REQUIRING APPLICANTS OF LARGE
CUSTOMER SITED STORAGE AND
SOLAR, AGGREGATED SOLAR AND
STORAGE TO PROVIDE EARLY NOTICE
TO THE CSP OF THE INSTALLATION
AND CHARACTERISTICS OF THESE
FACILITIES. THE INFORMATION WILL
BE HOUSED IN A CONSOLIDATED
ELECTRONIC FORMAT TO BE SHARED
WITH OTHER AGENCIES AND TO WHICH
THE PUBLIC MAY SEEK ACCESS. THIS
IS A SIMPLE NOTICE, PLANNING AND
TRANSPARENCY BILL LIMITED TO
LARGE COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
PROJECTS NONRESIDENTIAL THAT
WILL HELP THE STATE REACH ITS
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS. IT'S FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
. OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. A GOOD DAY. MR. VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS. HUNTER STERN, ON
BEHALF OF THE IBEW LOCAL 1245, I
WANT TO ADD QUICKLY THAT THERE'S
SOME SAFETY ISSUES THAT THIS
BILL HELPS TO ADDRESS. OUR
MEMBERS RESPONDING TO OUTAGES
AND CUSTOMER COMPLAINTS AND
POTENTIALLY, IF ONE OF THESE
DEVICES BEHIND THE METER HAS
GONE BAD, IT CAN PUT ENERGY BACK
OUT ON THE GRID. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
ONCE ANY SYSTEM IS ATTACHED TO A
HOME THAT'S ATTACHED TO THE
GRID, IT'S ON THE GRID. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. VALERIE
CHIRLA ALEJO'S, PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LAURA PALMER WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ISRAEL SALAS WITH SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MIKE MONAHAN
FOR STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. I'M EDSON
PEREZ. I'M A SENIOR PRINCIPAL
WITH ADVANCED ENERGY UNITED. WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB 3111
BECAUSE THE REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDED IN IT ARE DUPLICATIVE
AND CONTINUE TO BE WITH THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ARE
DUPLICATIVE, ONEROUS, EXPENSIVE,
AND WOULD HINDER THE EMERGING
EMERGING DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCE INDUSTRY, WHICH IS AN
INDUSTRY THAT'S CRUCIAL FOR
MEETING OUR CLEAN ENERGY AND
RELIABILITY GOALS AND TO BE
CLEAR, WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
REASONABLE REPORTING MEASURES TO
ENSURE PROPER PLANNING OF
DISTRIBUTION GRID UPGRADES. THE
ARB PROVIDERS ARE COMPLETELY
DEPENDENT ON THE DISTRIBUTION
GRID, SO THEY HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST IN ENSURING THAT IT
WORKS WELL IN THE LONG TERM. AND
THAT'S WHY THEY ALREADY SHARE
THE INFORMATION REQUIRED UNDER
THIS BILL WITH UTILITIES VIA
EXISTING INTERCONNECTION
PROCESSES, TARIFFS AND PROGRAMS,
SPECIFICALLY THROUGH RULE 21,
THE WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTION
ACCESS TARIFF, THE NET BILLING
TARIFF AND THE SELF-GENERATION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. IN ADDITION,
IN RELATION TO THE AGGREGATORS
RELEVANT INFORMATION, UPON
ENROLLING ANY CUSTOMER INTO AN
AGGREGATION PROGRAM LIKE THE
DEMAND SIDE GRID SUPPORT
PROGRAM, THE ENERGY COMMISSION
MANAGES THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM
DIRECTLY, SO THEY ALREADY HAVE
DIRECT VISIBILITY INTO AND
RELEASE AND SYSTEM PERFORMANCE.
AND IT'S NOTEWORTHY THAT THE PUC
RECENTLY ISSUED A NEW RULE
MAKING RELATED TO THE SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY OF DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEMS, AND IT DIDN'T MENTION
DERS AT ALL, FURTHER SHOWING
THAT A LACK OF INFORMATION IS
NOT A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN. AND
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS, WHICH MAKE
THE REPORTING LESS BURDENSOME
FOR AGGREGATORS. BUT THEY STILL
DON'T ADDRESS THE CORE OF THE
ISSUE. SO IF THE COMMITTEE
REALLY BELIEVES THAT THERE IS A
DATA SHARING AND AVAILABILITY
ISSUE REGARDING DERS, THE
PROPOSED POLICY SHOULD REALLY
LOOK INTO BOLSTERING THE
EXISTING REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
AND EXISTING REPORTING SYSTEMS,
RATHER THAN STARTING A WHOLE NEW
REPORTING PROCESS FROM SCRATCH
THAT WOULD OVERWHELM AN EMERGING
AND NECESSARY INDUSTRY AND CAUSE
THE CEC REALLY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. SO FOR
THESE REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU. MORNING. VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BRAD HEBNER OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION. THE PROPONENTS OF
THIS BILL TALK LIKE WE'RE FLYING
BLIND AND ENERGY PLANNING
WITHOUT ANY INFORMATION ABOUT
CUSTOMERS. SOLAR AND STORAGE AND
OTHER DERS. THAT IS FALSE. ONE
OF THE PROPONENTS JUST SAID WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT'S CONNECTED
TO THE GRID, AND THAT'S A SAFETY
ISSUE. THAT'S FALSE INFORMATION.
WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S CONNECTED
TO THE GRID, AND THAT'S THE DATA
THAT THE ENERGY COMMISSION USES
TO DO THEIR FORECASTING AND
PLANNING. THAT'S ACTIONABLE
INFORMATION. WHAT IS CONNECTED
TO THE GRID, WHAT HAS BEEN
INSTALLED? THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE SUBMISSION OF DATA ON
PERMIT APPLICATIONS AND
INTERCONNECTION APPLICATIONS.
THOSE ARE NOT USEFUL DATA
STREAMS FOR ENERGY PLANNING.
THERE ARE A LOT OF SYSTEMS THAT
APPLY FOR PERMITS AND NEVER GET
BUILT. AFTER YOU PUT IN FOR A
PERMIT, THERE'S LAND USE ISSUES
THAT COME UP. YOU NEED FINANCING
MANY OTHER THINGS. SAME FOR
INTERCONNECTION APPLICATIONS.
WHEN YOU SUBMIT AN
INTERCONNECTION APPLICATION, THE
UTILITY DOES AN ENGINEERING
REVIEW. THEY OFTEN COME BACK
WITH CONDITIONS THAT MAKE THE
PROJECT TOO EXPENSIVE. IT WOULD
BE BAD PLANNING FOR ENERGY
AGENCIES TO DO THEIR FORECASTING
BASED ON INTERCONNECTION
APPLICATIONS, AND PERMIT
APPLICATIONS. CDC DOES ITS
PLANNING BASED ON ACTUAL
INTERCONNECTIONS, AND THEY
ALREADY HAVE THAT DATA. THEY GET
IT DIRECTLY FROM THE UTILITIES.
THEY GET IT IN A FORMAT THAT
THEY'VE DESIGNED THAT IS USEFUL
TO THEM. THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE ENERGY STORAGE PROVIDERS
THAT AGGREGATE SYSTEMS FOR
PARTICIPATING IN LOAD REDUCTION
PROGRAMS TO SUBMIT REPORTS ON
INDIVIDUAL SYSTEMS THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THOSE PROGRAMS.
AGAIN, THE BILL GETS IT WRONG ON
WHAT INFORMATION WOULD BE USEFUL
IF THE ENERGY COMMISSION WANTS
TO INVESTIGATE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THESE DEMAND REDUCTION
PROGRAMS, THEY DON'T WANT TO
KNOW THE CAPACITY OF SYSTEMS
ENROLLED, THE NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS THAT HAVE SIGNED UP.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT THOSE
SYSTEMS ARE DOING, HOW MUCH
ENERGY WAS DISPATCHED IN
RESPONSE TO PROGRAM EVENTS. THEY
CAN GET THAT INFORMATION
DIRECTLY FROM THE ENTITIES THAT
ARE RUNNING THOSE PROGRAMS,
HAVING CAPACITY DATA FROM
INDIVIDUALLY ENROLLED SYSTEMS
WOULD NOT TELL THEM HOW
EFFECTIVE THE PROGRAMS ARE. ONE
OTHER THING, THIS THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE SENSITIVE INFORMATION
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. THIS WOULD
DISCOURAGE CUSTOMERS FROM
INVESTIGATING THEIR ENERGY
OPTIONS TO BEGIN WITH, IT WOULD
DRIVE UP COSTS AND SUPPRESS THE
MARKET. WE URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU. OTHERS METOOS. HI MEG
SNYDER, AXIOM ADVISORS, ON
BEHALF OF PEARLEX, OPPOSED.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ANDREW
ANTHONY, ON BEHALF OF TESLA,
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED. MISTER
CHAIR GRACIELA CASTILLO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
STORAGE ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION.
MCKINLEY THOMPSON. MORLEY, ON
BEHALF OF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION. IN
OPPOSITION. MATT KLOPFENSTEIN,
ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY. IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING.
MEMBERS. CHARLIE DONLIN WITH
STONE ADVOCACY AND I HAVE A LONG
LIST OF PARTIES IN OPPOSITION,
SO BEAR WITH ME. A ONE SON INC,
A SIP ENERGY, ECR SOLAR, ALAMEDA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY, ALASKA
MICROGRID GROUP ALBANY CLIMATE
ACTION COALITION, AMY'S ROOFING
AND SOLAR, AZTEC SOLAR INC, BAY
AREA CLEAN AIR COALITION,
BERKELEY ELECTRIFICATION,
WORKING GROUP, BP, C¢M RENTERS
COUNCIL, CALAVERAS COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT, CALIFORNIA INTERFAITH
POWER AND LIGHT, CALIFORNIANS
FOR ENERGY CHOICE, CALIFORNIANS
FOR WESTERN WILDERNESS CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY, CENTER
FOR COMMUNITY ENERGY, CHINO
VALLEY DEMOCRATIC CLUB, CITADEL
ROOFING, AND SOLAR. CIVIC WELL,
CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS.ORG,
CLIMATE ACTION CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE ACTION, MENDOCINO, THE
CLIMATE ALLIANCE OF SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY, THE CLIMATE CENTER,
CLIMATE HAWKS VOTE CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT SAN DIEGO
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS, ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE, COLLECTIVE
RESILIENCE, CONSUMER WATCHDOG,
CONTRA COSTA, MOVEON, CUSTOM
POWER SOLAR, COURAGEOUS
RESISTANCE OF THE DESERT, AND
INDIVISIBLE DEMOCRATS OF
SOUTHWEST, RIVERSIDE COUNTY, EQ
INSTITUTE, ECOLOGY CENTER,
ENERGY COALITION, ENERGY TOOL
BASED ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
COALITION FOR WATER EQUITY.
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION FOR OUR
CHILDREN, LOVE FRESNANS AGAINST
FRACKING, GLENDALE ENVIRONMENTAL
COALITION, GO GET IT, GREAT
ALTERNATIVES, GRASSROOTS
INSTITUTE, HAMMETT CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS, HUMBOLDT COALITION
FOR CLEAN ENERGY, INDIVISIBLE
SAN JOSE, LOCAL CLEAN ENERGY
ALLIANCE, LONG BEACH GRAY
PANTHERS, M-CUBED MICROGRID
RESOURCE COALITION, MUTUAL
HOUSING COALITION, CALIFORNIA,
NAPA CLIMATE NOW, NORTH CAROLINA
CLIMATE CHANGE ALLIANCE. CAN YOU
GIVE US AN ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY
YOU'RE GOING TO READ OFF HERE?
THERE'S PROBABLY 30 MORE. NO,
WE'LL PASS ON THAT. WE GET TO
JUST THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WAS
THAT OPPOSITION OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS?
ALL RIGHT, I WANT TO HEAR THE
LAST 30. OKAY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, YES. YOU KNOW, I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT WE TOOK A LOT
OF AMENDMENTS IN ASSEMBLY,
PARTICULARLY TO ADDRESS THE
PRIVACY CONCERNS. AND, YOU KNOW,
BUILDING PERMITS ARE ALREADY
PUBLIC INFORMATION AND CAN BE
ACCESSED FROM LOCAL PERMITTING
AGENCIES. AND YOU KNOW, THIS
ONLY WE LIMITED IT TO DEVELOPERS
WHO HAVE A NET WORTH OF 6
MILLION AND HAVE A NET INCOME OF
AT LEAST 2 MILLION OVER THE
PRECEDING TWO YEARS. AND SO I
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION, HERE
TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS. BUT I
THINK WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK
ON THIS BILL. AND I THINK IT'S A
GOOD BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I'M JUST
TRYING TO MAKE SURE YOU'VE TAKEN
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. YES,
SIR. OKAY. AND THEY WILL
REQUIRE, NOTICES ARE FILED AT A
TIME OF THE PERMIT TO INSTALL OR
INTERCONNECT, THE DRE OR
AGGREGATED, I SHOULD SAY DRE
DER, WHICH EVER COMES FIRST
REQUIRE AGGREGATORS TO PROVIDE
NOTICES WHEN PROGRAMS ARE
INITIATED AND TWICE A YEAR
THEREAFTER AND REQUIRE NOTICES
ARE SUBMITTED IN AN ELECTRICAL
FORMAT DETERMINED BY THE CEC
INSTEAD OF REQUIRING A PDF. IS
THAT CORRECT? OKAY, YES. SO AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME, IF WE GET
A MOTION, WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT,
WE TAKE A VOTE ON THIS. THANK
YOU. AND YOUR NEXT ONE IS FOR
ITEM 14 AB 3263. YOU MAY GO
RIGHT AHEAD. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATOR, I AGAIN, I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALL YOUR WORK AND WORKING WITH
OUR STAFF ON, GETTING THIS THIS
BILL AND THE CHAIR TO A GOOD
PLACE. AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING ALL
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL 3263
WOULD STABILIZE ELECTRIC
ELECTRICITY RATE FLUCTUATIONS BY
ALLOWING AN ELECTRIC UTILITY TO
REQUEST CPUC AUTHORIZATION TO
FINANCE ONGOING WILDFIRE
MITIGATION EFFORTS AS WELL AS
COSTS DERIVED FROM DECLARED
STATE OF EMERGENCIES THROUGH THE
USE OF BONDS. EXISTING LAW
ALLOWS ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO
SEEK CPUC AUTHORIZATION TO TAKE
OUT BONDS AND TIE THEM TO
RATEPAYER BILLS, OR SECURITIZE
THE BONDS TO PAY FOR JUST AND
REASONABLE COST, AS DETERMINED
BY THE PUC. AS WILDFIRE SEASONS
GROW LONGER AND MORE
DESTRUCTIVE, ELECTRIC UTILITIES
HAVE INCREASED THEIR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND OTHER FORMS OF
WILDFIRE MITIGATION. THE
ASSOCIATED COSTS WITH THESE
EFFORTS ARE TYPICALLY REQUIRED
TO BE RECOVERED BY ELECTRIC
UTILITIES WITHIN 12 MONTHS,
WITHOUT THE OPTION OF STRETCHING
OUT THE RECOVERY PERIOD, WITH
FINANCING MECHANISMS LIKE A
BOND, CONSTANT WILDFIRE
MITIGATION HAS LED TO
SIGNIFICANT RATE HIKES FOR
RATEPAYERS. ADDITIONALLY, THE
STORM RECOVERY COSTS FROM THE
PAST COUPLE OF WINTERS WILL
LIKELY LEAD TO AN ADDITIONAL
RATE SPIKE UPON THOSE COSTS
BEING DEEMED JUST AND REASONABLE
AND INCORPORATED WITHIN RATES.
AB 3263 SEEKS TO CODIFY THE
PRUDENT USE OF BONDS TO HELP
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED RATE RELIEF
ON OUR ENERGY BILLS. HERE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS ADAM
SMITH FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
ADAM SMITH, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON, SHARING OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB 3263 S¼ APPLAUDS
THE LEADERSHIP OF THIS COMMITTEE
ON THE ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY.
WE'VE BEEN HERE FOR THE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS. WE'VE HEARD
THE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS AND
PERSPECTIVES FROM THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS HERE. WE SEE RATES
RISING. WE'RE ALL LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO SMOOTH THE SPIKES AND
OFFER RELIEF TO ELECTRIC
CUSTOMERS. THAT'S WHY WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
FORWARD AND STRONGLY SUPPORT IT
TODAY. AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
AUTHOR, AB 3263 WOULD ALLOW
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS TO FILE
AN APPLICATION REQUESTING THE
PUC ISSUE US A FINANCING ORDER
THAT AUTHORIZES THE RECOVERY OF
WILDFIRE RELATED EXPENSES
THROUGH BONDS. OUR WILDFIRE AND
MANAGEMENT WORK IS APPROVED UP
FRONT BY THE COMMISSION AND ALSO
INDEPENDENTLY, THE OFFICE OF
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY. IT
IS NECESSARY TO KEEP OUR SYSTEM
SAFE, BUT THIS IMPORTANT WORK
HAS COST AND WILL CONTINUE TO IN
THE FUTURE. VEG MANAGEMENT CAN
BE UP TO 10% OF A CUSTOMER'S
BILL. OUR BROADER WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS SEEK TO HARDEN
THE GRID SO THAT CAN COME DOWN
OVER TIME. BUT IT'S THE REALITY
WE LIVE IN TODAY. THIS BILL PUTS
AN IMPORTANT TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX
TO HELP SMOOTH THESE NECESSARY
COSTS OUT OVER TIME. THE BILL
ALSO MAINTAINS THE PUC
DISCRETION TO DETERMINE IF
SECURITIZATION MAKES SENSE. IT
GIVES THE LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
TO APPROVE AN APPLICATION. IF IT
DOES, THE UTILITIES CAN SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS TO SECURITIZE SOME
OF THESE WILDFIRE RELATED
EXPENSES. IF THE CPUC APPROVES
THAT REQUEST, IT WILL REDUCE THE
MONTHLY BILLS OF OUR CUSTOMERS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL
MANAGE RATE INCREASES CAUSED BY
THE IMMEDIATE NEED TO HARDEN OUR
ELECTRIC SYSTEM AGAINST WILDFIRE
AND DELIVER ON OUR SHARED PUBLIC
SAFETY AND AFFORDABILITY GOALS
FOR THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT, WE
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT IT AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
YES. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES, GOOD
MORNING, BRANDON EBCLC, PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC. I'LL TRY NOT
TO REPEAT WHAT THE AUTHOR OR
EDISON JUST SAID, BUT WE ARE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL, MATT BAKER, WHEN HE WAS
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S DIRECTOR,
TESTIFIED IN THIS VERY COMMITTEE
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO AND WAS
ASKED TO SUGGEST POTENTIAL IDEAS
TO REDUCE RATES. ONE OF HIS
PRIMARY RESPONSES WAS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL PROPOSES. WE
SHOULD FINANCE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT COSTS WITH RECOVERY
BONDS, VEGETATION MANAGEMENT, AS
ADAM SAID, IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
INDIVIDUAL COSTS ON BILLS TODAY
DUE TO A LOT OF LEGISLATIVE AND
REGULATORY CHANGES IN THE LAST
SIX YEARS TO ADDRESS SIGNIFICANT
WILDFIRE RISK, THOSE COSTS HAVE
GROWN FROM ROUGHLY $300 MILLION
FOR PG AND E UP TO $2 BILLION IN
2022. TREE TRIMMING IS 10% OF AN
AVERAGE CUSTOMER BILL. ABOUT $20
A MONTH, WE THINK THAT THIS IS
ONE OF THE MOST PRUDENT AREAS
WHERE WE CAN SPREAD OUT THESE
COSTS OVER TIME, ADDRESSING
INTERGENERATIONAL CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS BILL THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED,
WE CUT DOWN TREES. THEY DON'T
GROW BACK. THE NEXT YEAR. WE ARE
SEEING MAINTENANCE REDUCTIONS
JUST SIMPLY BECAUSE WE REMOVE A
TREE. THE NEXT YEAR WE GO BACK.
WE JUST HAVE TO WEED WHACK THE
GROUND. IT'S THERE'S REDUCTIONS
FOR DECADES TO COME. SO WE THINK
THIS BILL IS PRUDENT, THEY THEY
OFTEN SAY THAT THE BEST TIME TO
PLANT A TREE WAS TEN YEARS AGO.
THE BEST TIME TO FINANCE THEIR
COST IS TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
NEED TO STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. HUNTER STERN, ON
BEHALF OF IBEW 1245 AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HEARING SEEING NONE, WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION, ARE YOU THE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION?
YES, SIR. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
MY NAME IS KATIE MORRISON. I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF TURN OPPOSING
AB 3263 SECURITIZATION OF
UTILITY COSTS IS A TOOL THAT CAN
PROVIDE RELIEF TO UTILITY RATES
BY PACKAGING CERTAIN UTILITY
COSTS INTO A RECOVERY BOND,
FINANCED AT A LOWER RATES AND
PAID OFF VIA A FIXED CHARGE ON
UTILITY BILLS FOR CAPITAL
PROJECTS, THE FINANCING COSTS OF
SECURITIZATIONS IS TYPICALLY
MORE AFFORDABLE THAN THE,
INCLUDING THE COST AND RATES,
BECAUSE THE RATE OF RETURN PAID
ON CAPITAL IS PAID BY THE
CUSTOMERS, THIS IS NOT THE CASE
WITH VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
OTHER O&M COSTS, WHICH ARE PASS
THROUGH COSTS WITH NO RATE OF
RETURN ASSOCIATED WITH THEM. THE
ABILITY TO SECURITIZE COSTS IS
NOT LIMITLESS. THERE IS AN UPPER
LIMIT OF THE AMOUNT THAT CAN BE
SECURITIZED AT FAVORABLE
FINANCING RATES, AND
SECURITIZATION SHOULD BE TREATED
AS AN EXTRAORDINARY SOLUTION AND
USED ONLY IN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES. DESPITE THE FACT
THAT CPUC CAN ALREADY CHOOSE TO
SECURITIZE UTILITY OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS WHEN THE
UTILITY SEEKS APPROVAL OF THOSE
COSTS, THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
UTILITIES TO REVISIT COSTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN ADDRESSED BY
THE CPUC AND REMOVE CERTAIN O&M
COSTS FROM RATES, AND THEN
SECURITIZE THEM AS AN INITIAL
MATTER. AS I NOTED, O&M IS A
PASS THROUGH COST AND THERE IS
NOT THE RATEPAYER BENEFIT OF
AVOIDING SHAREHOLDER PROFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH CAP, AS THERE
WOULD BE WITH CAPITAL COSTS.
SECOND, UTILITIES CAN ALREADY
ASK THE COMMISSION TO SECURITIZE
O&M COSTS WHEN SEEKING APPROVAL
OF THESE COSTS. THE COMMISSION
CAN DETERMINE WHEN, IF AND WHEN
SECURITIZATION IS IN THE
RATEPAYER INTEREST. AB 3263
GIVES, A SECOND CHANCE AT THE
CUP. IT'S A MISUSE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES. THESE
COSTS ARE ALREADY INCLUDED IN
RATES, AND THIS IS ALLOWING A
RETROACTIVE CHANGE TO HOW THOSE
COSTS ARE BEING COLLECTED.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT BENEFITS
CURRENT CUSTOMERS. BUT DOES LESS
TO HELP FUTURE RATEPAYERS. NOT
ALL TREES ARE REMOVED, MOST ARE
JUST TRIMMED. FOR INSTANCE, S¼
IN ITS CURRENT GRC HAS A ASSUMED
5% REMOVAL RATE. AND 95% TRIM
RATE, THE POTENTIAL
SECURITIZATION ALSO BENEFITS
CURRENT UTILITY CUSTOMERS, BUT
PASSES CURRENT COSTS ON TO
FUTURE RATEPAYERS. RATEPAYERS.
FROM 15 YEARS FROM NOW, MY
LITTLE KIDS WILL BE WHEN THEY
ARE ADULTS WILL BE PAYING FOR
TODAY'S VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
WHILE TURN AGREES THAT THE
AFFORDABILITY OF RATES IS
CERTAINLY A CRISIS, SECURITIZING
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT COSTS IS
NOT THE SOLUTION. TURN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HEARING
AND SEEING NONE. BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBER? VICE CHAIR.
YOU KNOW ALL RIGHT,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, YES, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. OKAY. AND WE HAVE A DO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. AND
I'LL JUST CLEARLY STATE THE
AMENDMENT IS A CHANGE TO THE
AMENDMENT IN THE ANALYSIS,
INSTEAD OF DELETING PARAGRAPH B,
WE ARE AMENDING THE LANGUAGE TO
AUTHORIZE THE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS TO SUBMIT
APPLICATION APPLICATIONS TO THE
CPUC FOR REVIEW. THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT APPLICATIONS ARE
SECURED FOR SECURITIZATION OF
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT EXPENSES,
CONTINUE TO UNDERGO THE SCRUTINY
OF THE EXISTING CPUC REVIEW,
INCLUDING ENSURING THEY ARE IN
THE PUBLIC'S INTEREST, JUST AND
REASONABLE AND BENEFICIAL
COMPARED TO OTHER FINANCIAL
OPTIONS SO THAT CORRECT? YES.
THANK YOU. SO CAN I ASK? YES,
SENATOR DODD? YES. SORRY TO BE
LATE ON THIS. SO THIS JUST SETS
UP A PROCEDURE FOR THE PUC TO
CONSIDER IT. DOES IT MANDATE IT?
IT JUST A CONSIDERATION. IT'S
PERMISSIVE. IT'S NOT A MANDATE
OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATORS.
THANK YOU, NEXT UP, WHO WAS IS
MISS WILSON. YOU'RE UP. YOU'RE
PRESENTING, FILE ITEM SIX, AB
1588. DOES THAT WORK FOR YOU?
NOPE. FOLLOWING M SIX 1588.
SOUNDS GREAT. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. SENATORS, I
WOULD LIKE TO FIRST START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME AND MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL.
WE STILL GOOD TO GO? JUST MAKING
SURE. OKAY. NO NO, NO, I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE STILL GOOD TO
GO, I, YOU KNOW, I'LL START OFF
BY SAYING I, I AM ACCEPTING, THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, I'VE
COMMITTED TO THE CHAIR, TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS OVER SUMMER RECESS
TO ADDRESS BROADBAND
AFFORDABILITY. AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, THE CHAIR IS
ALLOWING FLEXIBILITY TO COME UP
WITH AN APPROPRIATE SOLUTION
WITH ALL INVOLVED, ROUGHLY 3.5
MILLION CALIFORNIANS STILL LACK
INTERNET ACCESS, LARGELY DUE TO
AFFORDABILITY. FUNDING FOR THE
AFFORDABILITY CONNECTIVITY
PROGRAM, ALSO KNOWN AS ACP,
EXPIRED IN MAY, LEAVING MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WONDERING HOW
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO AFFORD
INTERNET, WHICH HAS BECOME A
NECESSITY FOR JUST ABOUT EVERY
ASPECT OF PEOPLE'S LIVES, FROM
SCHOOL TO WORK TO HEALTH CARE TO
BANKING AND SO MUCH MORE.
CONGRESS HAS SINCE DECLINED TO
CONTINUE FUNDING THE ACP IN
SPITE OF CALLS TO KEEP AMERICANS
CONNECTED FROM EVEN THE WHITE
HOUSE, AS CONGRESS HAS FAILED TO
ACT AND NO EXPECTATION THEY WILL
DO SO IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
FUTURE. IT IS INCUMBENT THAT THE
STATE TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION TO
ENSURE WE CONTINUE TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. THE LIFELINE
SERVICE IS AN EXISTING PROGRAM
FOR ESSENTIAL COMMUNICATION IN
TODAY'S ERA. BROADBAND IS AN
ESSENTIAL COMMUNICATION TOOL AND
SHOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE USE IN
THE LIFELINE SERVICE PROGRAM.
OFFERINGS AND SO THE COMMITTEE
AMENDS WOULD ALLOW EXPEDITED
ELIGIBLE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
CARRIER, ALSO KNOWN AS MTC
DESIGNATION FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PROVIDING STANDALONE BROADBAND
SERVICE AS A LIFELINE SERVICE.
THE EXISTING LIFE LIFELINE
PROGRAM DOES NOT OFFER A SUBSIDY
FOR BROADBAND AND REQUIRES AN
MTC DESIGNATION. LIKE I NOTED AT
THE BEGINNING, WE PLAN TO MEET
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO DISCUSS A
SOLUTION THAT ADDRESSES
EVERYONE'S CONCERNS FROM BOTH
THE PROPONENTS TO THE OPPONENTS,
AND WE COMMIT TO THIS COMMITTEE
TO WORK ON A SOLUTION THAT WORKS
FOR CALIFORNIANS AND ENSURE WE
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS LETICIA
ALEJANDREZ, THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND COMMUNICATIONS,
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY TECHNOLOGY
FUND, ALSO KNOWN AS KNOWN AS
CTF. THANK YOU. YOU'LL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I AM LETICIA ALEJANDREZ
WITH THE CALIFORNIA EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY FUND, THE SPONSOR OF
AB 1588. WE EXPRESS OUR DEEPEST
GRATITUDE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT FOR THE 5.8 MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS OF DIGITALLY
DISADVANTAGED CALIFORNIANS. AB
1588 IS A MAJOR MISSING PIECE OF
STATE POLICY REQUIRED TO CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. AB 1588 IS
NECESSARY. EVERY LEGAL EXPERT
HAS ADVISED THAT LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY IS REQUIRED TO EXPAND
LIFELINE. THERE IS AN URGENCY TO
THIS BILL. THE AFFORDABLE
CONNECTIVITY PROGRAM, AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON HAS
STATED, HAS ENDED AS OF MAY 20TH
4TH MAY 2024. THIS LEAVES 5.8
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE OR WHO WERE ELIGIBLE
FOR ACP WITHOUT ASSURANCE OF
AFFORDABLE INTERNET. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
CALIFORNIA ENROLLED NEARLY 3
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS IN THE ACP.
THAT'S NEARLY 50, WHICH IS 1
MILLION MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE IN THE NATION. AND THIS
WAS DONE IN LESS THAN TWO YEARS
IN CONTRAST, LIFELINE HAS BEEN
IN EXISTENCE FOR MORE THAN FOUR
DECADES AND HAS ABOUT 1.1
MILLION PARTICIPANTS, WHICH IS
ABOUT 30% OF ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS
. IT IS WITH THIS LENS THAT CETF
SHARES WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO
ACTUALLY REACH LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS, AND STATE THIS
INTENT IN AB 1588. NOW IS WHAT
WE RECOMMEND. ESTABLISH GOALS
FOR ENROLLMENT RATES.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS IMPORTANT FOR
LIFELINE. REQUIRE REGULAR
REPORTING ON PROGRESS TO THE
CALIFORNIA BROADBAND COUNCIL.
MAKE A STRATEGIC INVESTMENT IN
OUTREACH AND ADVERTISING TO
MAXIMIZE ENROLLMENT BY WORKING
WITH COMMUNITY AND ETHNIC MEDIA,
WHICH IS PART OF A LARGER
DIGITAL EQUITY ECOSYSTEM. THE
DESIGN AS LIFELINE IS DESIGNED,
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE 12
ESSENTIAL COMPONENTS OF THE
DIGITAL ECOSYSTEM TO BE
INCLUDED. REMEMBER, ACCESS
DELAYED IS ACCESS DENIED. WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
ALEJANDRO SOLIS, ON BEHALF OF LA
COOPERATIVA CAMPESINA OF
CALIFORNIA, LOS AMIGOS DE LA
COMUNIDAD, FIRST DAY FOUNDATION
AND PROTEUS, ALL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, TONY ANDERSON FROM
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES, SERVING 400,000
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
SUPPORT DILLONLIAM ON BEHALF OF
THE SOLANO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MARVIN PINEDA, ON BEHALF OF
LOS AMIGOS DE LA COMUNIDAD,
ACTUALLY AND INLAND COALITION
FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE AND
CALIFORNIA HUMAN DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU. JOSH GAGER, ON BEHALF
OF THE SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION COME FORWARD NOW.
WELL, OPPOSITION. I'M SORRY.
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN SUPPORT NOW.
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ARE YOU
PRIMARY? YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AMANDA GOLDEN
WITH CAL BROADBAND AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN PRINT. WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR, HER STAFF
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING ON
THE AMENDMENTS THAT CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON EXPANDING
LIFELINE TO INCLUDE A BROADBAND
OFFERING DURING SUMMER RECESS.
AS NOTED, THE FEDERAL AFFORDABLE
CONNECTIVITY PROGRAM WAS A
SUBSIDY PROGRAM THAT GAVE
CONSUMERS A $30 VOUCHER TO
UTILIZE FOR A BROADBAND PLAN OF
THEIR CHOICE AND DID NOT INCLUDE
ONEROUS REQUIREMENTS ON
PROVIDERS THAT PARTICIPATED,
WHICH LED TO A WELL PROMOTED,
WELL UTILIZED PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY CONGRESS DID NOT
REFUND THAT PROGRAM, BUT THE ACP
GIVES CALIFORNIA A ROADMAP TO
DEVELOP A SUBSIDY FOR BROADBAND
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
THERE IS STILL A LOT OF WORK TO
BE DONE, THOUGH. OVER THE
INTERIM OR I'M SORRY, OVER THE
RECESS, WE ARE DEDICATED TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
DETERMINE A FEW KEY AREAS. WHAT
WILL THE SUBSIDY FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS BE? WHAT, IF ANY,
INCREASE IN THE CURRENT CPUC
SURCHARGE AUTHORITY IS NEEDED?
WHAT WILL THE REQUIREMENTS BE OF
PROVIDERS IF THEY CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE? WHAT WILL THE
ELIGIBILITY PARAMETERS FOR
PARTICIPANTS BE AND WHAT
GUARDRAILS ON THE CPUC ARE
NEEDED TO BE TO SET UP AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT IS FOLLOWED? WE
UNDERSTAND THE LOSS THAT
OCCURRED WHEN ACP WAS NOT
REFUNDED BY CONGRESS, AND ARE
DEDICATED TO FINDING A WORKABLE
SOLUTION FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
NEED IT. THANK YOU. YES. GOOD
MORNING, AUDRA HARTMAN, ON
BEHALF OF QUALCOMM, WE HAVE AN
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
BILL. BUT WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN, WE WERE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE OVER
THE SUMMER RECESS, AND WE REALLY
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR THE
LANGUAGE ON MTC, WHICH ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS REALLY LIKE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
YOLANDA BENSON WITH US TELECOM,
THE BROADBAND ASSOCIATION. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR. WE'VE
COMMITTED TO HER THAT AS
STAKEHOLDERS, WE WOULD SIT DOWN
TO COME UP WITH THE PROGRAM AS
OUTLINED BY CAL BROADBAND IN
THEIR TESTIMONY, AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THE BILL. SO AT THIS TIME, WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE TO THE BILL IN
PRINT, BUT WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO FIND A
SOLUTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS JONATHAN ARAMBULA,
ON BEHALF OF CTIA, THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRIES, SIMILAR TO THE OTHER
SPEAKERS, WERE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL IN PRINT, BUT LOOK FORWARD
TO A FUN SUMMER RECESS AND, YOU
KNOW, HOPEFULLY FIGURING IT OUT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MISTER
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS ROXANNE GOULD
WITH THE WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE
ASSOCIATION. I'D JUST SAY DITTO
TO CAL BROADBAND US TELECOM. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THROUGHOUT THE BREAK. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHRISTOPHER
RODRIGUEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS?
NO, I'M GOING TO THANK THE
AUTHOR, FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE THE WORK IN THIS AREA.
I'LL KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS, I
LIKE I THINK 11 YEARS AGO, I DID
THE BROADBAND EXTENSION FOR
WIRELESS. BOTH. SENATOR PADILLA
AND MYSELF AT THE TIME, AND WE
KNOW THE NEED AND THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDERSERVED AND
THEIR WIRELESS DEVICES. AND SO
WE CLEARLY UNDERSTAND BROADBAND.
AND AGAIN, I SHARE THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE END OF
THE ACP ON CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM. I
SUPPORT THE EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
CAN'T AFFORD INTERNET PLANS, BUT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
THE LANGUAGE RIGHT AND TO ENSURE
THAT THE CHANGES TO LIFELINE
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL BENEFITS
WITHOUT BURDENS ON OUR
RATEPAYERS AND THAT'S ALWAYS
SOMETHING I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
AND I KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING
YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT AS WELL.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THE WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. AND THIS
COMMITTEE'S, COMMITTEE IS
COMMITTED TO WORK ON THIS BILL
AND ENSURE THAT WE STRIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE AS IT MOVES
THROUGH THE PROCESS. AND, I'LL
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE AT THIS POINT
. THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR. AND
ON BEHALF OF THE ALMOST 6
MILLION PEOPLE THAT NEED US TO
CLOSE THIS DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
COME UP WITH THE AS YOU NOTED,
THE BALANCED AND RIGHT SOLUTION,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
OKAY. AND JUST STATE AGAIN, WE
APPRECIATE YOU WILLING TO MEET
WITH THOSE STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE
BREAK. AND, YOU KNOW, WE HOPE IT
ALL GOES WELL. BUT WE'LL ALSO
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO PULL THE
BILL BACK. UNDERSTOOD. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. I THINK SO.
ALL RIGHT. SIMILAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN AND SHE WILL BE
PRESENTING. FILE ITEM 16 AB
3256. WHEN YOU'RE READY, YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. TODAY I
PRESENT AB 3256. AS CALIFORNIANS
ARE SEEING SOME OF THE HIGHEST
ELECTRIC BILLS IN THE NATION
SIMULTANEOUSLY, INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES ARE BOASTING RECORD
PROFITS. THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE HAS REVIEWED OVER $14
BILLION IN WILDFIRE AND
EMERGENCY RELATED COST RECOVERY
REQUESTS SINCE 2020. INVESTOR
OWNED ELECTRIC CORPORATIONS ARE
PERMITTED TO REQUEST COST
RECOVERY THROUGH REGULATORY
ACCOUNTS, WHICH FALL OUTSIDE OF
THE GENERAL RATE CASES.
BALANCING ACCOUNTS ARE USED FOR
COSTS THAT ARE EXPECTED AND
OCCUR REGULARLY, WHILE
MEMORANDUM ACCOUNTS ARE USED FOR
MORE VOLATILE YEAR TO YEAR
COSTS. COSTS RECORDED IN MEMO
ACCOUNTS ARE SUBJECT TO A
REASONABLENESS REVIEW, WITH THE
POTENTIAL FOR INCLUSION IN RATES
, BUT RECOVERY IS NOT
GUARANTEED. WILDFIRE AND
CATASTROPHIC RELATE CATASTROPHE
RELATED BUDGET REQUESTS HAVE
BECOME THE NORM AND ARE
PARTIALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
EXORBITANT RATES WE ARE SEEING.
AB 3256 AIMS TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
BY REQUIRING THE PUC TO AUDIT
ELECTRIC CORPORATIONS BALANCING
AND MEMO ACCOUNTS TO DETERMINE
IF, NUMBER ONE, THE COSTS IN THE
ACCOUNTS WAS AUTHORIZED. NUMBER
TWO, WHETHER THE CORPORATION
COMPLIED WITH THE TERMS
IDENTIFIED BY THE PUC. AND
NUMBER THREE, MOST IMPORTANTLY,
THE RATE IMPACT TO CUSTOMERS. IF
THE PUC DETERMINES THAT ANY
ACTUAL COSTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SUBMITTED AND COLLECTED FROM
CUSTOMERS, IT WILL DENY THE
CORPORATION A SECOND RECOVERY OF
THESE SAME COSTS. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NOW WE'LL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. DO WE HAVE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE. DO WE
HAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? DO
WE HAVE PRIMARY AND OPPOSITION?
IF WE HAVE IF YOU'RE A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION, YOU'LL
HAVE TWO MINUTES. HI. VALERIE
CHIRLA ALEJO'S, PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY, AND, WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, BUT WE
HAVE SEEN, AND LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS AS ACCEPTED BY THE
AUTHOR, AND LOOK FORWARD TO
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS, ALONG
WITH SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC,
WE HAVE WE ARE REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS. WE FEEL THAT THEY'RE
IN CONCEPT. THEY'RE GOOD. AND SO
AS SOON AS THEIR BILLS IN PRINT,
WE HOPE TO MAYBE REMOVE
OPPOSITION OR CHANGE, REEVALUATE
OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. YEAH. NO
JOKE. AGAIN. OKAY CATHERINE
BORG, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
WILL BE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND COMMITTEE. THANKS.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION IN
BETWEEN HEARINGS? SEEING NONE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? HEARING AND
SEEING? NONE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. OKAY AND WE HAVE A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS AND
AMENDMENTS. SIMPLY STATES DELETE
LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE ACCOUNTS TO
BE CLOSED. SECTION 2GB2. AM I
CORRECT? THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME, WE'LL LOOK FOR A MOTION ON
THIS MEASURE. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER AUTHORS IN THE ROOM AT THE
TIME? WELL AND I SAW MR. NORMAN
HERE. HE LEFT OUT. I JUST WANTED
TO SAY I'M HAPPY TO HEAR THAT
HIS DAUGHTER'S HOME SAFELY AND
RECOVERING. SO I'M WISHING HER
NOTHING BUT THE BEST. SO THANK
YOU. WE'RE WAITING FOR AUTHORS,
AS WELL AS MEMBERS, TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. SO, WE'LL TAKE A
SLIGHT RECESS.
TO KIND OF RECONVENE THE SENATE
ENERGY COMMITTEE. AND I SEE WE
HAVE AN AUTHOR. WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADDIS, AND SHE WILL BE
PRESENTING AB 2847 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WHEN YOU'RE READY, YOU
MAY BEGIN. WELL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, CHAIR, STAFF AND
ADVOCATES, AS YOU MENTIONED, I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB 2847, THE
RATEPAYER TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. AND I DO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT ENERGY RATES
ARE SKYROCKETING, IMPACTING REAL
PEOPLE ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IN
JUST THREE YEARS, RESIDENTIAL
ELECTRICITY RATES HAVE INCREASED
63% FOR PG AND E CUSTOMERS, AND
52% FOR SOCAL EDISON CUSTOMERS.
WE KNOW THAT FAMILIES ARE
STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR MONTHLY
BILLS, AND WITH NO END IN SIGHT,
WE'RE ALL LEFT WONDERING JUST
HOW HIGH THESE BILLS WILL CLIMB.
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY TIME TO
PROVIDE RELIEF. RESIDENTS OF OUR
STATE DESERVE TO KNOW TWO
THINGS. FIRST, WHAT TO EXPECT
WHEN THEY OPEN THEIR MONTHLY
ENERGY BILL. AND SECOND, THAT
ALL OF THE COSTS INCLUDED IN
THEIR BILL ARE FAIR AND
REASONABLE. HAVING THIS
INFORMATION CAN IN TURN LOWER
COSTS FOR EVERYONE. SO UNDER
CURRENT LAW, CALIFORNIA UTILITY
CUSTOMERS PAY FOR UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH RATES.
TYPICALLY, WHEN UTILITIES
REQUEST INFORMATION OR REQUEST
PERMISSION TO MAKE CAPITAL
PROJECT EXPENDITURES AND RECOVER
COSTS FROM RATEPAYERS, THEY ARE
ONLY REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LIST PRICE
OF THE ASSET AND THE IMPACT ON
RATES IN THE SHORT TERM. THIS
LEAVES RATEPAYERS IN THE DARK
WITHOUT IMPORTANT INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW THESE TRACES WILL
IMPACT RATES IN THE FUTURE. SO
WE DO HAVE A SOLUTION WHICH IS
TO SHINE A LIGHT ON THE LONG
TERM IMPACTS OF UTILITIES
CHOICES THROUGH AB 2487, AND
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE UTILITIES
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
LONG TERM COSTS OF CAPITAL
EXPENSES UP FRONT WHEN REQUESTED
BY THE PUC. THIS WILL PROVIDE
THE COMMISSION, RATEPAYER
ADVOCATES AND HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS WITH INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO DETERMINE WHETHER
UTILITIES SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
PASS THESE COSTS ALONG TO
CUSTOMERS. JOINING ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS KATIE
MARCHIONE OF THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK, GOOD MORNING AGAIN, MY
NAME IS KATIE MORRISON, AND I AM
HERE ON BEHALF OF TURN AS A
SPONSOR OF AB 2847 AB 2847 WOULD
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE UTILITY
SHOULD ALWAYS BE PREPARED TO
PROVIDE NOT JUST THE PRICE TAG
OF A CAPITAL PROJECT, BUT THE
COST OF THE PROJECT OVER THE
LIFETIME OF THE ASSET UTILITY
CAPITAL PROJECTS. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ASSETS THAT
SEEKS RATEPAYER RECOVERY FOR ARE
TYPICALLY PAID FOR OVER THE LIFE
OF THAT. THAT PROJECT AND THAT
ASSET. IN THIS WAY, THEY'RE LIKE
A HOME MORTGAGE. WHEN YOU SIGN
YOUR HOME MORTGAGE, THE LAW
REQUIRES THAT THE PROVIDER
DISCLOSE TO YOU NOT JUST THE
AMOUNT OF YOUR MORTGAGE AND YOUR
MONTHLY PAYMENT, BUT THE TOTAL
AMOUNT THAT WILL BE PAID OVER
THE LIFE OF THAT MORTGAGE.
BECAUSE WITH THE PREMIUMS, THE
TOTAL COST PAID WILL BE MUCH
MORE THAN YOUR ORIGINAL MORTGAGE
AMOUNT. SIMILARLY, BECAUSE OF
THE COST OF SHAREHOLDER RETURNS
AND FINANCING, RATEPAYERS PAY
MUCH MORE THAN THE LIST COST OF
A CAPITAL PROJECT. WHEN THE
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED, IT
SHOWS THAT RATEPAYERS OFTEN PAY
MULTIPLES OF THE PRICE TAG.
HOWEVER, THE UTILITIES RARELY
DISCLOSE THIS DATA POINT.
TYPICALLY, A COST RECOVERY
APPLICATION INCLUDES ONLY THE
PRICE TAG OF THE PROJECT AND THE
REVENUE REQUIREMENT OVER THE
RATE CASE PERIOD, OR THE NEAR
TERM. THIS INFORMATION IS
INSUFFICIENT TO ASSESS THE LONG
TERM IMPACT ON RATES, AND
WHETHER THE BENEFITS OF THE
PROJECT WILL ULTIMATELY OUTWEIGH
ITS COST. AB 2847 WOULD CREATE A
PROCESS FOR THE COMMISSION TO
REQUEST THIS INFORMATION WHEN IT
IS REQUIRED FOR THEIR
CONSIDERATION OF A UTILITY
REQUEST. THIS BILL INCREASES THE
TRANSPARENCY OF UTILITY REQUESTS
FOR FUNDING, AND IT PROVIDES THE
COMMISSION WITH MORE INFORMATION
WHEN ASSESSING THE VALUE OF
PROPOSED PROJECTS, IT WILL
REQUIRE RELIANCE ON ESTIMATES,
BUT EVEN ESTIMATES, ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY ARE PAIRED WITH THE
INPUTS TO THOSE ESTIMATES, CAN
BE A HELPFUL AND ILLUSTRATIVE
DATA POINT TO THE COMMISSION'S
DELIBERATION DELIBERATIONS. IN A
TIME WHERE UTILITIES ARE BOTH
ADDRESSING WILDFIRE RISK AND OUR
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS AND RATES ARE
INCREASINGLY UNAFFORDABLE, THE
COMMISSION ROLE, CONSIDERING
WHETHER PROPOSED WORK IS JUST
AND REASONABLE, IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER. AB 2847
PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT DATA POINT
TO HELP GUIDE THAT DETERMINATION
AND TURN RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU. MARK
FENSTERMAKER FOR PENINSULA CLEAN
ENERGY IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIRMAN. MY NAME IS DAN
JACOBSEN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP
IN SUPPORT. NOW WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, PRIMARY WITNESS. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS AGAIN WITH
SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC IN
OPPOSITION TO 2047, AGAIN, NO
JOKES. SORRY, SIR, BUT I WILL
TELL YOU, I FEEL A LITTLE
NERVOUS ABOUT WEARING A JACKET
THAT LOOKS LIKE I TOOK IT OUT OF
MY DAD'S CLOSET, SO IT'S A
LITTLE NERVOUS. IT'S ALREADY
NERVE WRACKING BEING UP HERE,
BUT LOOKING LIKE A LITTLE KID IN
A BIG, OVERSIZE JACKET. IT'S
EVEN WORSE. IS THAT GOOD? IS
THAT, I DON'T KNOW, COME TO MY
SHOW, IT'LL BE BETTER. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S MOVE ON. SO WE DO A
WE DO OPPOSE THE BILL. HOWEVER,
THE CONCEPT OF THE BILL IN TERMS
OF MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION FOR THE RATEPAYER,
TO HAVE OR FOR TURN TO HAVE SO
THAT RATES SO WE KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING INTO RATES. AND SO
THAT IN TURN WE DON'T CHARGE THE
RATEPAYERS MORE THAN THEY HAVE
TO. WE COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
THAT. ABSOLUTELY. IN FACT, AS
YOU SAW EARLIER TODAY, WE'RE
SPONSORING AB 1912, WHICH IS
PACHECO'S BILL. TO HELP ENSURE
THAT THERE'S MORE INFORMATION
FOR LEGISLATORS TO HAVE IN TERMS
OF BACKGROUND AND MAKE A, YOU
KNOW, GOOD DECISIONS ON THESE
BILLS TO MAKE SURE THAT RATES
ARE NOT HIGH. AND, WE ARE
DEFINITELY ON THE FOREFRONT OF
KEEPING ENERGY AFFORDABLE. THAT
SAID, I THINK THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR IS NOT ONE THAT WE AT
LEAST THE WAY IN WHICH IT'S
GOING. IT'S NOT ONE THAT WE
NECESSARILY AGREE. WE HAVE
DIFFERENT WAYS IN LOOKING AT
THIS AND WHERE WE THINK THAT
PROVIDING, JUST A LOT OF
ESTIMATION COULD ACTUALLY BE BAD
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT EVERY
YEAR IS GOING TO BE. THERE'S
SOMETIMES THERE'S COVID,
SOMETIMES IT'S HOTTER THAN OTHER
TIMES. I MEAN, THERE'S JUST A
LOT OF, INPUTS THERE THAT WE
CAN'T ACCOUNT FOR. NUMBER ONE.
AND TWO, THIS IS A DISCUSSION
THAT'S ALREADY HAPPENING.
HAPPENING AT THE PUC. AND IT'S A
IT'S A FIGHT THAT IS TAKING
PLACE AT THE PUC. THAT'S BEING
BROUGHT BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE.
SO WE FEEL THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE HANDLED,
THERE STILL BY THEIR I MEAN,
WITHIN THE PUC. AND WE ALSO
NOTED THAT IN THE ANALYSIS, THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL NOTE THAT
UNCOVERING LONG TERM IMPACT
REQUIRES MORE FUNDS, MORE ROUNDS
OF DISCOVERY, AND TAKING UP
RESOURCES IS VERY EXPENSIVE FOR
THEM. IT WOULD BE VERY EXPENSIVE
FOR US AS WELL, TO DO A LOT OF
ROUNDS OF DISCOVERY TO PROVIDE.
SO WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED. IS
GOING TO BE JUST AS EXPENSIVE
FOR US AS IT IS FOR TERN, AND WE
FEEL THAT HAVING THIS DISCUSSION
WOULD BE MORE PRODUCTIVE, WITHIN
THE PUC, WHERE IT BELONGS,
RATHER THAN IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. YOU CAN COME FORWARD
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO THIS
MEASURE, SENATOR NEWMAN, SO I'M
GLAD TO MOVE THE BILL WHEN WE
FINALLY HAVE A QUORUM, SO I JUST
WANT THE MEMBER TO KNOW THAT SHE
AND I WERE JUST IN A HEARING
ROOM. THAT WAS A LITTLE BIT
FULLER THAN HERE. WE HAVE
MULTIPLE HEARINGS GOING ON AT
ONCE. SO AT SOME POINT WE'LL
HAVE A QUORUM HERE. AND AT THAT
TIME, THANK YOU. AND, I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND THEY JUST SIMPLY STATE ADD
LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES THE PUC,
PUC TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
ADDED ESTIMATIONS REQUIRED BY
THIS BILL ARE NEEDED TO REVIEW
THE APPLICATION FOR CAPITAL
EXPENDITURES SUBMITTED BY THE
ELECTRICAL OR GAS CORPORATIONS.
IS THAT CORRECT? CORRECT. AND I
THINK YOU STATED IN YOUR OPENING
ABOUT CERTAINLY WE ALL NEED
CERTAINTY. AND THIS BILL HAS
HELPED TO PROVIDE THAT
CERTAINTY. ALL CUSTOMERS,
WHETHER IT'S RESIDENTIAL,
COMMERCIAL, YOU NAME IT. THEY
NEED CERTAINTY IN THEIR BILL.
AND THIS HELPS US TO PROVIDE
THAT. SO AT THIS POINT, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
WHEN THE TIME COMES. IF WE EVER
GET A QUORUM, WE'LL SEE IF WE
CAN. THANK YOU. GET THAT DONE.
THANK YOU. NEXT UP, I SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARNER.
PRESENTING FILE ITEM 11 AB 2666.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
GOOD. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
AND SENATORS. FIRST, I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND HIS AMAZING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS BILL. I ACCEPT ALL
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION. SHOULD THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD TODAY. TODAY I'M
PRESENTING AB 2666 A TO B
SPECIAL, WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE
CPUC, FOLLOWING THE APPROVAL OF
GENERAL RATE CASE, OF EACH
GENERAL RATE CASE KNOWN AS THE
GRC, TO REVIEW WHICH COSTS
DIFFERED FROM THE GRC FORECAST
FOR EACH ELECTRIC, ELECTRICAL OR
GAS CORPORATION, AND TO ADJUST
THE AUTHORIZED REVENUE AT THE
NEXT GENERAL RATE CASE BASED ON
ACTUAL COSTS. I REQUESTED AN
AUDIT TO SHOW, AND THE RESULTS
SHOW THAT PROFITS ARE INCREASING
. FOR MOST OF THE LAST YEARS, SD
GENIE HAD SOME OF THE HIGHEST
RATES IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND
SHOWED RECORD PROFITS FAR BEYOND
THEIR GENERAL RATE CASE APPROVED
PROFITS. TODAY, MORE THAN 25% OF
SD CUSTOMERS ARE IN MORE THAN OR
MORE THAN 30 DAYS BEHIND ON
THEIR UTILITY BILL. IF THE
UTILITIES ARE NOT MAKING PROFITS
ON THE BACKS OF WORKING PEOPLE,
THIS BILL WILL DO NOTHING BUT
BRING LIGHT TO THE AREAS IN
WHICH LEGITIMATE SAVINGS WERE
MADE AND ADJUST DOWN THE TRUE
COSTS OF DOING BUSINESS FOR SUCH
AN IMPORTANT ACCOUNTABILITY,
TRANSPARENCY AND GOOD GOVERNANCE
MEASURE. I REALLY APPLAUD THE
COMMITTEE ON HELPING ME ADDRESS
THE REAL COST OF COST OF LIVING
ISSUES. CALIFORNIANS, AND
ESPECIALLY SAN DIEGANS, ARE
PAYING. AS I HAVE DEMONSTRATED
FOR SIX YEARS, I'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND ANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES ON ANY ISSUES
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD.
TODAY, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HEARING. SEEING NONE. ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT? YES. ALL RIGHT THEN.
BRAD HEBNER, THE SOLAR AND
STORAGE ASSOCIATION JUST WANT TO
STATE OUR SUPPORT. SO WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT. MR. CHAIR MARK
FENSTERMAKER FROM PENINSULA
CLEAN ENERGY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING ALL OF
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
YOU MAY COME FORWARD. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. ISRAEL SALAS WITH SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION BASED ON
THE AMENDMENTS AS REFLECTED IN
THE ANALYSIS. AND WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS, SAME CATHERINE BORG
WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION TODAY.
THANK YOU TO THE SPONSOR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US.
THANK YOU. VALERIE CHIRLA OF
ALEJO'S PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY. THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
US. AND WE'RE GOING TO REVIEW
THE AMENDMENTS AND LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE GETTING CLOSE. THANK YOU.
GOT IT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OR IN BETWEEN? OKAY. OUR MADE
UP. NO OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WE BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND THE
QUESTIONS. SENATOR BECKER. YEAH.
THANKS I JUST WANT TO NOTE THIS.
THIS BILL IS BASED ON THE POA
RECOMMENDATIONS, AND YOU'RE
REALLY TAKING THE TIME TO, PUT
INTO LAW, MAKE SURE WE DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU SAYING YOU HAD A
LOT OF PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OPPOSITION OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS, AND THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME. I'LL REMOVE
THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS?
HEARING AND SEEING? NONE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND WE DID WORK ON
THIS BILL AND THE ASSEMBLY. IF
YOU WATCHED THAT HEARING, YOU'LL
SEE IT WAS JUST ME AND MY
UTILITY BILL, BECAUSE THAT
CANNOT BE THE BASIS FOR WHAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO PAY IN CALIFORNIA
FOR ENERGY. AND SO WITH THIS, I
HOPE THIS BRINGS TRANSPARENCY
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE AN AUTHOR. WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AND
SHE'S PRESENTING FILE ITEM NINE,
AB 2239. WHEN YOU'RE READY, YOU
MAY BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. FIRST, I WANT TO
START WITH SAYING I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I
ACKNOWLEDGED WITH THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
BE ADOPTED UNTIL AFTER THIS BILL
IS HEARD IN JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
LATER TODAY. SHOULD THIS BILL
MOVE OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE,
HOWEVER, I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T ALSO SAY THAT THE
DEFINITION OF COVERED ENTITIES,
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS AND THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE AND COVERED UNDER
THIS BILL, IS MISSING SOME KEY
GUARDRAILS THAT I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING ON WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF TO ADD TO THIS
BILL AT A LATER DATE. AB 2239
ADDRESSES A CRITICAL ISSUE IN
OUR DIGITAL AGE, ENSURING
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO BROADBAND
INTERNET SERVICES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AS YOU WILL HEAR
FROM MY WITNESSES, CALIFORNIANS
WHO LIVE IN AREAS WITH
PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISCONNECTED IN LIGHT OF THE
INCREASING RELIANCE ON DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGIES FOR EDUCATION,
WORK, HEALTHCARE AND
COMMUNICATION. IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE PREVENT DIGITAL
DISCRIMINATION AND PROMOTE
FAIRNESS AND ACCESS SUCH FOR
SUCH A CRITICAL, ESSENTIAL
SERVICE. HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO,
AB 2239 ADOPTS THE FCC'S
DEFINITION OF DIGITAL
DISCRIMINATION, WHICH
ESTABLISHES A CLEAR DEFINITION
FOR DIGITAL DISCRIMINATION OF
ACCESS. THIS DEFINITION PROVIDES
A FRAMEWORK FOR IDENTIFYING AND
ADDRESSING DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES IN BROADBAND INTERNET
PROVISION. IN ADDITION, AB 2239
EXPRESSLY PROHIBITS INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO PROHIBITS
COVERED ENTITIES FROM ENGAGING
IN DIGITAL DISCRIMINATION OF
ACCESS, WHICH IS DEFINED AS
POLICIES OR PRACTICES THAT
DISPARATELY OR DIFFERENTIALLY
IMPACT CONSUMERS ACCESS BASED ON
THE FACTORS SUCH AS RACE,
ETHNICITY, RELIGION, OR NATIONAL
ORIGIN. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT ARE PAUL GOODMAN, LEGAL
COUNSEL AT THE CENTER FOR
ACCESSIBLE TECHNOLOGY, AND
PATRICK MESICK, DIRECTOR FOR
OAKLAND UNDIVIDED. THANK YOU.
EACH WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
CHAIR. BRADFORD VICE CHAIR,
DELAY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M PATRICK MESICK,
DIRECTOR OF OAKLAND UNDIVIDED, A
COLLECTIVE IMPACT EQUITY BASED
INITIATIVE THAT UNITES THE CITY
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND TRUSTED
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE PURSUIT OF DIGITAL EQUITY
FOR OAKLAND'S 37,000
DISCONNECTED HOUSEHOLDS. WE ARE
A CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2239,
ALONGSIDE THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR DIGITAL EQUITY,
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION,
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA, THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP. I'M
SPEAKING TODAY FOR ALL OF US AND
THE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS OUR
COALITION COLLECTIVELY SERVES AS
MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARED THE
FACTS OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STARK. RACE AND
INCOME ARE THE BEST PREDICTORS
OF WHETHER YOU'RE STUCK ON THE
WRONG SIDE OF THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. WE'VE SEEN THESE
DISPARITIES PRIMARILY IN TWO
WAYS QUALITY AND PRICING.
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME AND
THOSE THAT ARE PREDOMINANTLY
NONWHITE CONSISTENTLY,
SYSTEMATICALLY HAVE FEWER
OPTIONS, RECEIVE WORSE SERVICE,
AND PAY MORE FOR THAT SERVICE.
IN OAKLAND, WE TESTED MORE THAN
15,000 DATA POINTS AND
DOCUMENTED THAT CONNECTIONS IN
THE HIGHEST INCOME, WIDEST ZIP
CODE RECEIVE SERVICE TEN TIMES
FASTER THAN IN OUR POOREST,
LEAST WHITE. DESPITE SUBSCRIBING
TO AND PAYING FOR SIMILAR TIERS
OF SERVICE, A PATTERN MIRRORING
REDLINING FROM THE 1930S. IN
FACT, 75% OF LOCATIONS WE TESTED
DIDN'T GET THE SPEEDS FAST
ENOUGH TO BE CONSIDERED SERVED
UNDER STATE RULES. OUR PARTNERS
AT THE FRESNO COALITION FOR
DIGITAL INCLUSION HAVE 15
MILLION DATA POINTS COLLECTED AT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF LOCATIONS
OVER THIS TIME, DOCUMENTING THE
SAME PATTERN. YOU MIGHT ASSUME
THAT THESE WEALTHY COMMUNITIES
HAVE HIGHER QUALITY CONNECTIONS
BECAUSE THEY PAY MORE FOR
INTERNET, BUT THE OPPOSITE IS
TRUE POOR COMMUNITIES PAY MORE
FOR WORSE. INTERNET IN LÀ, THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
HAS DOCUMENTED THAT THE
ADVERTISED COST OF INTERNET
SERVICE IS SYSTEMATICALLY HIGHER
IN NEIGHBORHOODS WITH HIGHER
POVERTY RATES. INDEPENDENT
RESEARCH HAS VERIFIED THESE
FINDINGS AT SCALE. A TEAM AT UC
SANTA BARBARA STUDIED MORE THAN
35,000 RESIDENTIAL ADDRESSES IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND
CONCLUDED THAT, QUOTE, WEALTHY
AREAS RECEIVE MORE BANDWIDTH FOR
LESS MONEY. THIS ISN'T A
PHENOMENON LIMITED TO LÀ. TWO
MINUTES. SORRY, YOU'RE AT YOUR
TWO MINUTES. OKAY, I'LL CLOSE
WITH THIS ON BEHALF OF THE BILLS
, SPONSORED SPONSORS AND
EXTENSIVE LIST OF SUPPORTERS, I
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO SEE PAST
THE SMOKESCREENS THE CONFUSING
HYPOTHETICALS AND THE SCARE
MONGERING I'VE KNOWN I'VE SEEN
DISCUSSED WITH THIS BILL. THIS
IS THE SIGNAL. ALL OF THE NOISES
THAT YOUR TWO MINUTES, THE
STATUS QUO IS UNTENABLE AND
WRONG AND AB TWO TWO, THREE,
NINE IS APPROPRIATE AND
NECESSARY. THANK YOU NICK.
GOODNESS. GOOD MORNING. I'M PAUL
GOODMAN WITH THE CENTER FOR
ACCESSIBLE TECHNOLOGY. I'VE
SPENT OVER THE PAST DECADE
LOOKING AT THE HISTORICAL
DISPARITIES IN BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT. AND I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT SPECIFICALLY THE
AMENDMENT, THE AMENDMENTS TO
THIS BILL. BUT I WANT TO START
WITH SOME HISTORICAL CONTEXT.
ONE OF THE MOST PERNICIOUS HARMS
OF SEGREGATION WAS THAT IT MADE
BLACK AND BROWN CHILDREN FEEL
INFERIOR TO WHITE CHILDREN.
THERE'S A HOST OF SOCIAL
SCIENCES, SAID, BECAUSE THEY
WENT TO SCHOOLS THAT WEREN'T AS
GOOD AS WHITE SCHOOLS, BECAUSE
THEY LIVED IN AREAS THAT WERE
FOOD DESERTS, AND BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SUBPAR OR NONEXISTENT
COMMUNICATION SERVICES. THEY
GROW UP THINKING THEY'RE LESS
DESERVING THAN THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS. THAT IS SHAMEFUL.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO NOTE
HISTORICALLY, IS THE SUPREME
COURT DESEGREGATED SCHOOLS IN
BROWN VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION,
BUT THAT DESEGREGATION WAS SLOW.
SO THE SUPREME COURT CAME BACK
WITH THE BROWN TWO DECISION, AND
THEY UNFORTUNATELY USED THE TERM
WITH ALL DELIBERATE SPEED AND
OPPONENTS OF DESEGREGATION USE
THAT TERM DELIBERATE TO SLOW
DOWN OR STOP DESEGREGATION OF
SCHOOLS. THE ELIGIBLE ENTITIES
AMENDMENT IS THE ALL DELIBERATE
SPEED OF THIS BILL. FOR ENTITIES
WITH A GOOD FAITH COMMITMENT TO
BROADBAND EQUITY, THAT LANGUAGE
IS GOING TO MAKE THEM NERVOUS
ABOUT ANY POTENTIAL RISK. AND
FOR BAD FAITH ENTITIES, THEY
WILL USE THAT LANGUAGE TO BLOCK
OR DELAY DEPLOYMENT. THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE. ADDITIONALLY, THE
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES LANGUAGE IS
NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE FCC
ORDER. THE FCC IS A REGULATORY
AGENCY AND MONITORS ITS OWN
RULES, AND THEREFORE IT'S
RELATIVELY EASY FOR THE FCC TO
SAY, HEY, WE NEED TO CHANGE
WHO'S AN ELIGIBLE ENTITY. AND IN
FACT, THE FCC ORDER SAYS, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO DECIDE WHETHER TO,
SAY, LANDLORDS OR ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES OR NOT YET. SO INSTEAD,
THE ENFORCEMENT HERE IS GOING TO
BE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND WE'RE
GOING TO END UP WITH A HOST OF
REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY, BECAUSE
EVERY JURISDICTION WILL END UP
WITH ITS OWN DEFINITION OF WHAT
AN ELIGIBLE ENTITY IS. AND I
WILL SAY FOR ME, THE MOST
FRUSTRATING PART IS BY GIVING
THIS EXPANSIVE DEFINITION OF
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES, WE ARE NOT
PLACING THE BLAME. AT YOUR TWO
MINUTES. WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU
TO CLOSE. YEAH, I'LL I'LL SAY
VERY QUICKLY, IN JUDAISM,
THERE'S A CONCEPT CALLED TIKKUN
OLAM. IT MEANS HEALING THE
WORLD. THE WORLD IS BROKEN AND
IT'S OUR DUTY TO TRY AND FIX IT.
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT PART OF
THAT IS THIS STATEMENT YOU'RE
NOT OBLIGED TO COMPLETE THE
WORK, BUT NEITHER ARE YOU FREE
TO DESIST FROM IT. I'M ASKING
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY TO CONTINUE
THAT WORK AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR
WE GET BROADBAND TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT MOST NEED IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES TO SUPPORT
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. PLEASE MR.
CHAIRMAN ORACIO GONZALEZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR DIGITAL EQUITY AND
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA, BOTH
CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND
STRONG SUPPORT. DAN SEAMAN, ON
BEHALF OF END POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA, IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION CO-SPONSOR GREAT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. NOW ALLIANCE FOR
A BETTER COMMUNITY, COMMUNITY
COALITION OF THE ANTELOPE VALLEY
, DESTINATION CRENSHAW ARTS FOR
LÀ COMMUNITIES AND SCHOOLS OF
LOS ANGELES, HEALING AND JUSTICE
CENTER, INNOVATIVE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. FAMILY IN SCHOOLS.
LATINO EQUALITY ALLIANCE, OUR
VOICE COMMUNITIES FOR QUALITY
EDUCATION, PARA LOS NINOS, SOUTH
EAST COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION, UNITED PARENTS AND
STUDENTS, AND THE ANGELINO
PROJECT, ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE IT. NEXT WITNESS
, ANNIE CHOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NICOLE WATERMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP CO-SPONSOR, FRESNO
COALITION FOR DIGITAL INCLUSION
AND UNITE LA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, BETH
MALINOWSKI WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YEAH
DOLORES HUERTA DE LA HUERTA
FOUNDATION. AND I JUST WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE THAT SLAVERY, IN
SLAVERY DAYS, THEY DENIED AN
EDUCATION, DENYING A DIGITAL
ACCESS IS ACTUALLY DOING EXACTLY
THE SAME THING, NOT ONLY DENYING
AN EDUCATION, BUT DENYING PEOPLE
THEIR FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MISS HUERTA. NEXT WITNESS,
JUANITA CHÁVEZ FROM THE DOLORES
HUERTA FOUNDATION. AND JUSTICE
FOR MY SISTER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. YESENIA CONTRERAS, DOLORES
HUERTA FOUNDATION. MY FAMILY IS
FROM ARVIN, CALIFORNIA. I GREW
UP IN ARVIN, CALIFORNIA, A SMALL
WORKING FARM TOWN AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MARVIN PINEDA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
FUND IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SASHA HOROWITZ, LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. JOSH GEIGER, ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
HELLO. MY NAME IS SHIRLEY LAM
WITH INSURED THE UNINSURED
PROJECT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL,
ALSO EXPRESSING SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY CLINIC
ASSOCIATION OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND EVERYONE ON THANK YOU
. HI. CYNTHIA DIAZ, DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY IMPACT WITH OAKLAND
UNDIVIDED, CO-SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL, REPRESENTING THE FOLLOWING
11 OAKLAND ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL OAKLAND
NAACP, HACK THE HOOD, THE UNITY
COUNCIL, OAKLAND YOUTH
COMMISSION, OUSD TECH REPAIR
PROGRAM, TECH EXCHANGE, URBAN
MONTESSORI CHARTER SCHOOL, YOUTH
UPRISING, KAPOR CENTER, AND
LIGHTHOUSE COMMUNITY PUBLIC
SCHOOL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS, STELLA JOHNSON, ON
BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BELLA KERN ON BEHALF
OF MICHELSON CENTER FOR PUBLIC
POLICY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY MORE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HEARING? SEEING NONE NOW
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
ARE YOU THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION? YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AMANDA CALDERON WITH CAL
BROADBAND. WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THE GOAL OF AB 2239, WE DISAGREE
WITH THE METHOD AND MUST OPPOSE
THE BILL. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE FCC RULED TO WHICH
THIS BILL IS MODELED AFTER, IS
UNDER LITIGATION AT THE FEDERAL
COURT. CURRENTLY WITH OPENING
ARGUMENTS BEGINNING IN
SEPTEMBER. THE DISAGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENCE IN
LIABILITY STANDARDS IS PART OF
THIS LITIGATION. SO UTILIZING
THE STANDARD IN STATE STATUTE IS
PREMATURE. A DISPARATE IMPACT
STANDARD DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
INTENT TO DISCRIMINATE AND
INVITES UNINTENTIONAL
CONSEQUENCES. IN THE
MARKETPLACE. PLAINTIFFS COULD
ALLEGE THAT FAILURE TO UPGRADE
OR DEPLOY NEW TECHNOLOGIES IN
ALL COMMUNITIES SIMULTANEOUSLY
HAS A DISPARATE IMPACT.
BROADBAND PROVIDERS CANNOT
DEPLOY EVERYWHERE AT ONCE
BECAUSE THE SITUATION WILL
INCREASE THE RISK OF LITIGATION.
IT MAY UNDERMINE THE WILLINGNESS
OF PROVIDERS TO UNDERTAKE NEW
DEPLOYMENTS OR NEW PROVIDERS TO
ENTER THE MARKET. WE HAVE
REQUESTED AN AMENDMENT TO CHANGE
THIS PROBLEMATIC STANDARD WITH
THE DISPARATE TREATMENT
LIABILITY STANDARD. A DISPARATE
TREATMENT STANDARD IS INTENT
BASED AND WOULD ENSURE THAT AB
2239 CREATES AN ENFORCEABLE
FRAMEWORK IN CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
RELYING ON THE DISPUTED ASPECTS
OF THE FCC RULE. UNDER A
DISPARATE TREATMENT STANDARD,
BROADBAND PROVIDERS WOULD HAVE A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THE LAW
AND WOULD NOT FEAR THE RISK OF
UNWARRANTED LITIGATION.
CURRENTLY, CALIFORNIA HAS THE
BENEFIT OF BEING THE SEAT OF
INVESTMENT FOR THE TECHNOLOGY
SECTOR, INCLUDING BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE POLICIES SUCH AS
IMPOSING A DISPARATE IMPACT
STANDARD WILL HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT REGARDING GROWTH UPGRADES
AND INNOVATION, ENSURING
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO EVERYONE, WHICH IS WHY
WE MUST OPPOSE AB 2239 AS IT
CONTINUES TO HAVE A DISPARATE
IMPACT STANDARD WHICH WILL HAVE
NEGATIVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. AND TO THE COMMITTEE, I'M
PASTOR ANDRE CHAPPELL FROM THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN EMPOWERMENT
COALITION. I AM WHAT YOU WOULD
CALL THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND IN
THE HOOD IN SOUTH CENTRAL LA, WE
WORK IN COMPTON, WATTS AREAS. WE
ARE ACTUALLY THE ONES THAT HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THIS PROBLEM, AND
WE LEAD OUR CONSTITUENTS AS
SUCH. LET ME BE CLEAR THIS THIS
MORNING, ENSURING THAT ALL
FAMILIES, ESPECIALLY PEOPLE OF
COLOR, ARE SERVED QUALITY
BROADBAND SERVICE IS VITAL TO
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA. THE
PROBLEM IS THIS BILL DOESN'T IS
NOT GOING TO DO THAT. IN FACT,
IT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO DO THE
OPPOSITE. IT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO
SLOW DOWN DEPLOYMENT FOR
BROADBAND FOR ALL. AND LIKE
WE'LL PROBABLY END PROGRAMS LIKE
THE ONES THAT I, I OFFERED TO
OUR COMMUNITY IN SOUTH LA, THE
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL IS REALLY
THE DEFINITION OF
DISCRIMINATION. CIVIL RIGHT LAWS
HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN DESIGNED
TO FIX SITUATIONS WHERE THE BAD
ACTORS, INTENTIONALLY. I
HIGHLIGHT THE WORD INTENTIONALLY
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF WHO THEY ARE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS BILL REALLY
TRIES TO EXPAND THE HISTORIC
STANDARD, INSTEAD, WITH A
DISPARATE IMPACT STANDARD THAT
WILL LIKELY RESULT IN BROADBAND
PROVIDERS BEING SERVED, BIG
LAWSUITS AND BIG PENALTIES. THIS
WILL ONLY LEAD TO THEM GIVING
LESS OF AN INVESTMENT, OR EVEN
SUPPORTING PROGRAMS LIKE THE
ONES THAT ARC DOES UNDER THIS
BILL. I REALLY WANT TO KNOW HOW
DO WE EXPECT THE BROADBAND
PROVIDER TO DECIDE WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO DO THEIR UPGRADES? IF
THEY DO IT IN SOUTH LA AND DON'T
DO IT IN COMPTON, WILL THEY BE
HIT WITH A BIG LAWSUIT? HOW DO
WE JUDGE THAT? THE OTHER
QUESTION I WANT TO KNOW IS HOW
DOES A BROADBAND PROVIDER
SUPPOSED TO WORK WITH A LOCAL
COMMUNITY GROUP TO PROVIDE
DISCOUNTED SERVICES TO CITIZENS
IF THEY'RE GOING TO BE PENALIZED
FOR NOT PROVIDING THAT SAME,
THAT SAME RESOURCE TO ANOTHER
COMMUNITY AT THE SAME TIME?
WELL, WE ALL KNOW THE ANSWER.
THEY CANNOT DO THAT ALL AT THE
SAME TIME. SO WHAT'S GOING TO BE
THE RESULT? AND I LEAVE YOU WITH
THIS, THIS IS ULTIMATELY GOING
TO BE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. AND I RESPECT THE AUTHOR
TREMENDOUSLY, THESE DEFINITIONS
OF DISCRIMINATION ARE NOT CLEAR.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO CAUSE
PROBLEMS WHERE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GET THE SUPPORT ANYMORE THAT
WE USED TO GET. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT, WITNESSES. IF YOUR.
ME TOO. JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION. PLEASE HI MEG
SNYDER, ACXIOM, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, OPPOSED. YOLANDA
BENSON, US TELECOM, THE
BROADBAND ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO 2239. ROXANNE GOULD
WITH THE WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. AUDRA
HARTMAN, ON BEHALF OF QUALCOMM,
ALSO OPPOSED DEAN TALLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION, OPPOSED.
JONATHAN ARAMBULA, ON BEHALF OF
CTIA, THE TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY. ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. CHRISTOPHER
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE CAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
HERE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE? AB 2239
HEARING, SEEING NONE, I'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I YOU
AND I HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT MY CONCERNS ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE IN LIABILITY
LANGUAGE, THE STANDARD, AND I
SHARE, SOME OF THE CONCERNS
ABOUT UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES,
BUT THAT IS A LEGAL MATTER. AND
SO I'M WILLING AT THIS POINT, AS
A COURTESY TO YOU, I'M GOING TO
GIVE YOU AN AYE VOTE TODAY WHEN
WE HAVE A QUORUM. BUT I RESERVE
MY RIGHT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
FLOOR. IF IT COMES TO THE FLOOR
TO MAKE A DIFFERENT VOTE. BUT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
AT SENATE JUDICIARY. SO THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE IT. SENATOR,
IT'D BE DODD. AYE. SENATOR DODD.
WELL, I CERTAINLY RESPECT, MISS
BARTA. GREAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
GREAT FRIEND. BUT ON THIS ONE, I
AM MORE TAKEN BY THE TESTIMONY
OF THE PRIMARY SPEAKERS AGAINST
THIS. AND WHILE I DO BELIEVE
THIS IS GOOD POLICY AND SUPPORT
THESE TYPE OF POLICIES ALL THE
TIME, THE SECOND PRIMARY, SIR, I
DIDN'T REMEMBER YOUR NAME. I'M
SORRY. YEAH I THAT IS THE
BIGGEST CONCERN, I THINK, THAT I
HAVE IN THIS. AND IT'S GOING TO
IT'S GOING TO CAUSE, YOU KNOW,
MORE PROBLEMS THAN IT'S GOING TO
SOLVE. AND SO I GUESS I'VE GOT
ONE QUESTION, TO THE TO THE
AUTHOR IS, WHY DON'T YOU JUST
TAKE AN AMENDMENT ON THE
STANDARD, AND LET'S SEE HOW THAT
WORKS, BECAUSE OTHERWISE I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO, WE'RE GOING TO
FIND THAT WITH A POLICY LIKE
THIS, THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GET ANYWHERE ANYWAY. SO WE CAN
GET THE POLICY IN PLACE RIGHT
NOW, BUT NOT HAVE, YOU KNOW,
NEEDLESS, YOU KNOW, LITIGATION
GOING FORWARD. I WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT. BEFORE WE CONTINUE,
SECRETARY, LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE.
DELHI. DELHI HERE. ASHBY. BECKER
BECKER. HERE. CABALLERO. DODD
HERE. DODD. HERE. DURAZZO
DURAZZO. HERE I. EGGMAN! HERE.
EGGMAN! HERE GONZALEZ. GROVE.
LIMÓN MIN. MIN. HERE NEWMAN.
HERE. NEWMAN. HERE. RUBIO
CIERTO. SKINNER STERN. STERN.
HERE. WILK PRESENT. WILK.
PRESENT ASHBY. HERE. ASHBY HERE.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF QUORUM.
MR. PRESIDENT. SENATOR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. BONTA, YOU MAKE, RESPOND
. SENATOR PLEASING TO, COMMON
REFRAINS THAT WE'VE HEARD AND,
ON ON THE ISSUE OF WHETHER OR
NOT THIS WILL SOMEHOW STYMIE
DEPLOYMENT OR MAKE ISP
PROVIDERS, SOMEHOW HESITANT TO
UPGRADE BROADBAND AND ENGAGE IN
PROVIDING INFRASTRUCTURE TO US,
THAT IS A COMMON REFRAIN THAT
HAS BEEN USED TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. AND JUST TO BE VERY
CLEAR, REQUIREMENTS THAT ISP
PROVIDERS APPLYING FOR AND
RECEIVING FEDERAL FUNDING COMMIT
TO OFFERING A LOW INCOME OPTION.
WE HEARD THAT SAME THING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ISP PROVIDERS
BACKUP POWER FOR THEIR NETWORKS
FOR THE FIRST 72 HOURS OF A
POWER OUTAGE TO ALLOW CONTINUOUS
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ACCESS. WE
HEARD THAT REFRAIN EXPANDING
CUSTOMER SERVICE STANDARDS FOR
PHONE SERVICE TO VOIP SAFETY
RULES REGARDING POLE
ATTACHMENTS, INVESTMENTS IN THE
STATE'S MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND
INITIATIVE. I CAN GO ON NET
NEUTRALITY RULES. FEDERAL AND
CALIFORNIAN, FEDERAL, FEDERAL
AND CALIFORNIA'S INCREASING THE
MINIMUM SPEED TO BE CONSIDERED
BROADBAND, REQUIRING MORE
SPECIFIC REPORTING ON SERVICES
VERSUS UNDERSERVED, UNSERVED
COMMUNITIES REQUIRING MORE
TRANSPARENT CUSTOMER SERVICE
STANDARDS. THE REFRAIN OF THE
CHICKEN LITTLE REFRAIN OF WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DEPLOY,
AND IT WILL STYMIE OUR ABILITY
TO INNOVATE, HAS BEEN USED TIME
AND TIME AGAIN BY INDUSTRY. THE
IMPACT OF THAT IS THAT IT MAKES
GOOD PEOPLE, LIKE THE PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESS, WORRY ABOUT
HAVING THE ABILITY TO HAVE A
BASIC SERVICE, AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICE IN INTERNET. WE CANNOT
FALL FOR THAT. IT IS TIME FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO APPLY A VERY HIGH
STANDARD OF DISPARATE IMPACT,
NOT DISPARATE TREATMENT TO THIS.
IN GRIGSBY DUKES POWER COMPANY
DOTHARD BE RAWLINSON, BROWN VÆ
BOARD OF EDUCATION, THE
DISPARATE IMPACT STANDARD WAS
THE STANDARD THAT WAS USED TO BE
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT PROTECTED
COMMUNITIES, PROTECTED
CLASSIFICATIONS WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SEEK RECOURSE IN THE
EVENT THAT THERE WAS A
DEMONSTRATED IMPACT AND
DISPARITY IN THE DEPLOYMENT OF
THOSE SERVICES. THIS IS NO
DIFFERENT. WE ARE AT THE POINT
NOW WHERE INTERNET SERVICE IS AN
ESSENTIAL RIGHT EFFECTIVELY, AND
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THAT HIGHER STANDARD. YEAH, WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT, THE CASES YOU
CITED, A NUMBER OF THOSE, WERE
WHEN I WAS IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND I SUPPORTED THEM ALL. WHAT
THIS DOES IS THIS SETS UP A
STANDARD THAT CREATES A REAL
PROBLEM IN MY MIND OF LITIGATION
AND UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE. SO I
GUESS WE JUST WE I DON'T THINK
WE DISAGREE ON THE POLICY. I
THINK WHAT WE DISAGREE ON IS,
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN, WHEN THERE'S
A PROBLEM WITH THE POLICY AND
SOMEBODY TRIES TO BRING AN
ACTION, WHETHER IT'S DISPARATE
VERSUS WHATEVER THE OTHER ONE
IS, I THINK YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
I'M SAYING I DO, SENATOR, AND IF
I MAY. SURE PLEASE, WE NEED TO
BE IN A POSITION RIGHT NOW AS
PUBLIC SERVANTS TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE PROTECTING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT IN
EDUCATION AND HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT WITH THE APPLICATION
OF THE DISPARATE IMPACT. AND ALL
OF THOSE INSTANCES, I'M SURE AND
CERTAIN THAT THERE WAS AN
ARGUMENT MADE AROUND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. BUT THE REAL LIFE
CONSEQUENCES TODAY ARE THAT
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES,
PEOPLE OF COLOR, LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT RECEIVING
THE KIND OF INTERNET SERVICE
THAT THEY NEED AND REQUIRE TO BE
ABLE TO LIVE. AND SO I'M WORRIED
ABOUT THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF NOT PROVIDING A VERY EXPLICIT
REMEDY TO THOSE COMMUNITIES,
WHICH THIS BILL DOES, TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT. OKAY SENATOR BECKER. THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
I KNOW YOU'RE VERY DEEPLY,
DEEPLY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW, I'VE
DISCUSSED THIS. SO WE DON'T HAVE
TO GO INTO ALL OF THEM. BUT, I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE NOT,
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE PREMISE AND THEN THE
IMPLEMENTATION. I MEAN, THEY'RE
NOT MONOPOLY PROVIDERS, RIGHT?
AND, YOU KNOW, MAYBE IF YOU WANT
TO APPLY AN OBLIGATION TO SERVE,
THEN WE NEED TO SHIFT TO MORE OF
A UTILITY MODEL OR SUCH. RIGHT.
WE DON'T THESE ARE NOT MONOPOLY
PROVIDERS. AND SO I GUESS, YOU
KNOW, I ASKED YOU FOR EXAMPLES
WHERE WE'VE SEEN THE DISPARATE
IMPACT STANDARD AND YOU GAVE ME
SOME IN, IN GOVERNMENT
DECISIONS, EDUCATION, ZONING,
HOUSING, BUT ARE THERE OTHER
EXAMPLES IN PRIVATE BUSINESSES.
AND THEN I GUESS IN THE FCC
APPROACH, THEY CREATED A
COMPLAINT PROCESS RATHER THAN A
LITIGATION. PROCESS. AND, YOU
KNOW, WHY DID YOU CHOOSE A
LITIGATE, A CIVIL LITIGATION
PROCESS? FOR, FOR THIS, I'LL
ADDRESS THE ISSUE AROUND THE
COMPLAINT PROCESS FIRST. SO THIS
BILL ACTUALLY, RIGHT NOW
INCLUDES AS A ENFORCEABLE
ENTITIES, THE OFFICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF CIVIL
RIGHTS, AS WELL AS PUBLIC
ATTORNEYS, IT HAS NO PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION, JUST TO BE
CLEAR, BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
DELETERIOUS AND, YOU KNOW,
ONGOING LAWSUITS COMING FROM
OTHERS, I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
PLACE THE ABILITY TO ISSUE A
COMPLAINT PROCESS THROUGH THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS, WHICH
THIS BILL DOES, AND ALSO TO BE
ABLE TO RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
TAKE ACTION WITH OUR PUBLIC
ATTORNEYS, OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL,
OUR PUBLIC, OUR CITY ATTORNEYS
AND PUBLIC AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS. AND THE REASON WHY
THAT'S IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE WHEN
THEY BRING LAWSUITS OR CLAIMS,
THEY HAVE TO DO SO BY FIRST
ACHIEVING A VERY HIGH STANDARD
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A PRIMA
FACIE CASE, TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT, THEY FIRST HAVE TO
IDENTIFY THAT THERE IS A
CHALLENGING POLICY OR PRACTICE.
THEY HAVE TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
A RELEVANT COMPARATIVE
POPULATION EXISTING. THEY HAVE
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS A
DEMONSTRATED ADVERSE IMPACT ON
THAT POPULATION, AND THEN THEY
HAVE TO DETERMINE THAT THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE DISPARITY IS
ACTUALLY CONNECTED TO AND
CAUSALLY RELATED TO THE SPECIFIC
POLICY OR PRACTICE THAT'S
OUTLINED THAT ESTABLISHMENT OF
THAT, THAT CRITERIA THAT'S USED
IS A VERY HIGH BAR FOR PUBLIC
ATTORNEYS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE TO
MEET. THEY HAVE TO KNOW THAT
SOMETHING'S PROBLEMATIC, AND
THEN THEY HAVE TO DO THEIR
HOMEWORK AND BRING FORWARD A
CASE THAT I'M SURE AFTER GOING
THROUGH THAT WOULD HAVE
INCREDIBLE LEGITIMACY TO BE ABLE
TO START THE CONVERSATION
THROUGH ACTION AROUND WHAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE. ULTIMATELY, THE
REMEDY IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF. SO THE ISP
PROVIDERS BASICALLY HAVE TO
CORRECT THE HARM. I THINK THAT'S
A FAIR THING FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO ASK OF OUR ISP PROVIDERS AND
OTHERS AS IT RELATES TO WHETHER
OR NOT THERE ARE KIND OF
PRIVATE, PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS OR
ENTITIES INVOLVED IN THIS, THE
DISPARATE IMPACT STANDARD HAS
BEEN APPLIED IN IN WORKFORCE
SETTINGS. THAT'S A PRIVATE
THAT'S A PRIVATE BANKER, CABINET
MAKER, WHATEVER. IT'S A PRIVATE
BUSINESS, ESSENTIAL BUSINESS
ENTITY WHERE WE'RE ESSENTIALLY
SAYING WE DON'T WANT
DISCRIMINATION TO EXIST. THE
CONCERN IS SO GREAT AS A STATE
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT DISCRIMINATION IS
NOT HAPPENING IN THOSE SETTINGS,
WHETHER IT'S IN A BUSINESS
SETTING WHERE THERE'S
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST AN ENTITY
BECAUSE, ALLEGED, BECAUSE THEY
ARE DISCRIMINATING AGAINST FOR
AGE REASONS, THE STATE AND THE
PUBLIC DOES ACTUALLY STEP INTO
THOSE SITUATIONS TO ESSENTIALLY
SAY, WE NEED TO PROTECT THE
RIGHT. AND IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT AND USES THE DISPARATE
IMPACT STANDARD TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT, WHICH IN SOME WAYS KIND OF
BROADENS THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
THE ONUS OF THE PUBLIC.
ATTORNEYS AND THE OFFICE OF
CIVIL RIGHTS TO ESTABLISH,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT SAYS WHOLE
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING IMPACTED
BY THIS, AND WE'RE USING OUR
PUBLIC DOLLARS AND RESOURCES IN
A VERY CONSERVATIVE WAY, BECAUSE
THAT'S OUR DIRECTIVE TO THEM TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. SO THOSE
THAT'S MY RESPONSE TO THOSE TWO
QUESTIONS. YEAH. NO, NO, NO, NO.
AND I THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW,
FIRST I APPRECIATE THAT. I THINK
THAT'S HELPFUL. AND I THINK, YOU
KNOW, WITH, YOU KNOW, TRUST FACE
IN MANY OF OUR CITY ATTORNEYS, I
THINK, YOU KNOW, I GUESS, AND
YOU AND I HAVE DISCUSSED THIS
AND I KNOW YOUR BACKGROUND AND I
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF ONE
ECONOMY FOR OVER A DECADE. AND
WE OUR FLAGSHIP PROGRAM WAS THE
BIG BRING IT HOME PROGRAM. BRING
IT HOME, WITH BARACK OBAMA AND
JOHN MCCAIN. BUT IT WAS REALLY
ABOUT BUILDING AFFORDABLE
BROADBAND, AFFORDABLE HOUSING,
APARTMENTS AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS AND HAVING
TRAINING YOUNG FOLKS THERE AND
PAYING THEM TO TRAIN OTHERS AND
I LOOKED AT THIS FOR A LONG
TIME. I'M JUST, YOU KNOW, WHERE
I COME DOWN IS THAT, YOU KNOW,
THESE ARE NOT MONOPOLY PROVIDERS
WHO HAVE A REGULATED RETURN.
AND, AND SO HAVING A LAWSUIT
REMEDY FOR THAT, TO, YOU KNOW,
WHEN THERE MAY NOT BE CLEAR
CASES OF DISCRIMINATION, I THINK
IS CONCERNING. BUT THE BIGGER
ISSUE FOR ME IS JUST, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE SPENDING $6 BILLION TO FIX
THIS PROBLEM. AND AS CHAIR OF
SUB TWO, I'VE HAD THE PUC IN
FRONT OF ME MANY TIMES ON THIS
ISSUE. AND I'VE ASKED THEM, WHAT
IS YOUR PLAN? I'VE TRIED TO GET
CLARIFICATION FROM THEM, HOW
MANY PEOPLE REMAIN TO BE SERVED?
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE UNSERVED,
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE UNDERSERVED?
AND WHAT IS OUR PLAN? AND DO WE
HAVE A PLAN TO GET TO ZERO? AND
I THINK RIGHT NOW THE BURDEN IS
ON US AS A STATE TO DO THAT. WE
PUT THE MONEY UP. THE FEDS ARE
PUTTING THE MONEY UP. WE HAVE
THE MONEY TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
AND, I'M CERTAINLY BE OPEN TO,
YOU KNOW, THIS BILL IN THE
FUTURE, BUT I THINK RIGHT NOW,
IF ANYONE SHOULD BE, YOU KNOW,
IT'S I WON'T SAY THAT IF
ANYONE'S RESPONSIBLE RIGHT NOW,
I'D SAY IT IS THE STATE WE HAVE
THIS MONEY. WE'VE HAD THIS MONEY
FOR THREE YEARS. IT'S OUR JOB TO
GO OUT AND MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE SERVED AND FRANKLY, I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR PLAN ON
THAT. AND THAT'S A WHOLE
DIFFERENT TOPIC, BUT RIGHT NOW,
I THINK WE'RE SPENDING THE
MONEY. IT'S OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE
THESE PEOPLE GET SERVED. SO
AGAIN, OPEN TO THIS IN THE
FUTURE, BUT I'LL LIKELY NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS. BUT I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS. SENATOR
EGGMAN, YOU KNOW, WE'RE NOT ONLY
IF YOU'RE ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OR YOU'RE THE AUTHOR,
YOU YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
WEIGHING IN. SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND I'M
SORRY I WASN'T HERE FOR A LOT OF
THE CONVERSATION. I, I, LIKE
OTHER MEMBERS, HAVE SOME OF THE
SIMILAR CONCERNS. THE IMPACT
VERSUS INTENT AND THE
MALICIOUSNESS OR THE, YOU KNOW,
I DON'T THINK ANYONE THINKS
COMPANIES ARE ACTING WITH
MALICIOUSNESS. I THINK, AS
PEOPLE HAVE POINTED OUT, OUR
HOUSING POLICIES AND EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT WE'VE DONE HAVE, HAVE
CREATED THE SITUATION, BUT I
COMMITTED TO YOU THAT I WAS
GOING TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL
TODAY AND TO HELP YOU GET IT TO
THE FLOOR. AND I WILL THANK YOU,
SENATOR STERN, I BELIEVE IS UP
NEXT. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYWOMAN,
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I
DON'T SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS
NECESSARILY AS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT THE OVERALL
CONTEXT OF THE LEGAL FRAMEWORK.
YOU'VE SET UP HERE, I THINK WE
CAN, FIND A WAY THROUGH THIS,
WITHOUT SORT OF THE BURDENS THAT
INTENT AND INTENT BASED STANDARD
WOULD REQUIRE. I KNOW THAT SOME
OF THAT WILL BE DISCUSSING IN
JUDICIARY IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD, BUT I DID WANT TO ASK,
I YOU'VE ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I DID. OKAY. SOME OF
THEM MIRROR, THE FROM A SCOPE
PERSPECTIVE, THE COVERED
ENTITIES IN THE FCC'S ORDER,
WHICH I KNOW IS SORT OF CREATED
A SERIES OF OTHER CHALLENGES
WITH THE BILL. AND NOW THERE'S
MORE FOLKS WHO ARE OPPOSED,
WE'RE HEARING FROM APARTMENT
OWNERS, FOLKS LIKE THAT, BUT
SORT OF SETTING THAT ADDITIONAL
COMPLICATION ASIDE, THIS IDEA OF
SORT OF MIRRORING ON THE FCC
ORDER. I WANT TO SEE IF I GET
YOUR COMMENT OR MAYBE EVEN YOUR
YOUR LEAD WITNESSES.
PERSPECTIVE, THE KIND OF BURDEN
SHIFTING FRAMEWORK THAT'S,
THAT'S MORE IN THE WEEDS OF THE
FCC ORDER AS OPPOSED TO THAT
SORT OF OVERALL ARCHITECTURE,
WHICH WE MIRROR. IS THERE A
PROBLEM WITH TRYING TO KIND OF
GET THAT GRANULAR WITH THIS
FRAMEWORK? IN OTHER WORDS, TO
STICK WITH YOUR IMPACT STANDARD,
BUT TO GET TOWARDS, LIKE WHEN DO
YOU ANTICIPATE, I GUESS, WOULD
THAT BE RESOLVED THROUGH
LITIGATION UNDER THE CURRENT
FRAMEWORK IN THE BILL? OR IS
THAT KIND OF THE BURDEN SHIFTING
FRAMEWORK AND SOME OF THE
DETAILS IN THE FCC ORDER, DO YOU
OR YOUR YOUR SPONSORS THINK THAT
THAT, IS BETTER LEFT TO THE
COURTS TO DECIDE, OR IS THERE A
WAY TO ADD A LITTLE MORE OF THAT
DETAIL HERE IN STATUTE SO PEOPLE
REALLY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING? AND IDEALLY, NO ONE HAS
TO GO TO COURT, RIGHT? BECAUSE,
I MEAN, I THINK THAT'S THE IDEAL
IS THAT OUR PROVIDERS DO THEIR
JOB AND WE DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A
HAMMER AND PEOPLE START
DELIVERING. AND SO THE MORE WE
SORT OF KNOW ABOUT WHAT THOSE
EVIDENTIARY THRESHOLDS WOULD BE
AND SORT OF HOW THAT WOULD ROLL,
IT JUST FEELS LIKE KIND OF
DISENTANGLE OURSELVES FROM THIS
BIG CONFLICT HERE. SO MAYBE YOU
HAVE A COMMENT OR OTHERS. YEAH,
I'LL COMMENT AND THEN ASK MY,
LEAD TESTIMONY WITNESS TO SPEAK
TO THIS AS WELL. I WANT TO JUST
KIND OF FIRST FRAME WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE FCC RIGHT NOW
AND OUR REGULATORY BODIES AND
WHETHER OR NOT AS OPPOSITION,
SPOKE TO THIS IS PREEMPTIVE, THE
FCC RIGHT NOW TOOK TWO YEARS TO
BE ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO COME
FORWARD WITH A DEFINITION OF
DIGITAL DISCRIMINATION OF
ACCESS. THEY DIDN'T DO SO
LIGHTLY, WILLY NILLY. THEY
THOUGHT THIS THROUGH AND THEY
INVOLVED A BROAD GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS AND ENTITIES TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. THE FACT THAT
WE NOW HAVE IN REGULATION
THROUGH THE FCC, THE A
DEFINITION AROUND DIGITAL
DISCRIMINATION OF ACCESS, WHICH
THIS MIRRORS, REALLY SPEAKS TO
THE FACT THAT DESPITE
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS, AS
SENATOR BECKER MENTIONED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, $6 BILLION, IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO KIND OF FIX THIS
PROBLEM, WE ARE NOT AT A POINT
YET WHERE WE CAN GUARANTEE OR
EVEN COME CLOSE TO ENSURING THAT
THERE WON'T BE AN EXECUTION OR
AN IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGE THAT
WILL CAUSE MANY COMMUNITIES TO
BE LEFT OUT. SO WHAT WE DO HAVE
HAPPENING, THOUGH, IS THAT THE
FCC IS A REGULATORY BODY. WE'VE
JUST HAD A LEGISLATIVE, FINDINGS
FROM THE RULINGS FROM THE
SUPREME COURT COME DOWN THAT
MAKE US KIND OF QUESTION WHETHER
OR NOT THE FCC OR ANY REGULATORY
AGENCY IS REALLY GOING TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE FORCE TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE, OPERATING AT
THE AT THEIR FULL STRENGTH WITH
CHEVRON. SO FOR CALIFORNIA TO
KIND OF STEP INTO THAT SPACE
RIGHT NOW AND LEAD AS WE DO AND
ESSENTIALLY SAY WE THROUGH
STATUTE ARE WANTING TO BE ABLE
TO DEFINE STATUTE STATUTORILY,
WHAT DIGITAL DISCRIMINATION OF
ACCESS IS A VERY IMPORTANT THING
TO HAPPEN IN THIS MOMENT RIGHT
NOW, PARTICULARLY GIVEN WHAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE, TO SPEAK TO THE
ISSUE AROUND KIND OF SHIFTING
THE BURDEN. I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING AT IS WHAT IS LINED OUT
IN A LOT OF THE KIND OF THE,
DISCRIMINATE DISPARATE IMPACT,
JURISPRUDENCE IS AROUND THE THIS
THE STAUNTON MEETING THAT
STANDARD OF PROOF, ESSENTIALLY,
I'M VERY OPEN TO CONSIDERING
INCLUDING THAT STANDARD OF
PROOF, IF YOU WILL, AS IT'S BEEN
LAID OUT, HISTORICALLY IN AND WE
KNOW THAT TO BE IDENTIFYING THE
CHALLENGE RELEVANT COMPARATIVE
POPULATION, DEMONSTRATING
ADVERSE IMPACT AND THEN
DEMONSTRATING THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF THE DISPARITY AND THE CAUSAL
LINKAGE BETWEEN THE SPECIFIC
POLICY AND PRACTICE AND THE
DISPARATE IMPACT ON COMMUNITY.
THAT IS ALREADY WHAT WE HAVE
USED BEFORE. I THINK I'M OPEN TO
CONSIDERING THAT AS SOMETHING
THAT WE COULD INCLUDE IN THIS
LEGISLATION. SHOULD IT, SHOULD
IT MOVE FORWARD? IT IS IN
KEEPING WITH,
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION
JURISPRUDENCE AND WITH THE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL. DO YOU
MIND IF I ASK THE LEAD WITNESS
ON JUST THAT POINT AND
ABSOLUTELY NO. AND REALLY TRYING
TO ALIGN TO THE AUTHOR'S POINT,
STICKING WITH YOUR YOUR INTENT
HERE. TO NOT NECESSARILY GO TO
AN INTENT BASED FRAMEWORK, BUT
BUT ONE THAT THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY WILL KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING THEMSELVES INTO. AND,
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE ONE
AMENDMENT THERE THAT THE
DISPARATE IMPACT DOESN'T INCLUDE
POLICIES AND PRACTICES JUSTIFIED
BY A SUBSTANTIAL, LEGITIMATE
BUSINESS INTEREST. BUT IF THAT
WERE SORT OF FED INTO THIS, I
GUESS MORE GRANULAR STANDARD OF
PROOF SO THAT THEY WOULD KNOW,
IS THERE, DO YOU SEE, A WAY TO,
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT, AND IN A WAY
THAT WE WOULDN'T BE UNDERCUT BY,
SAY, FEDERAL LITIGATION AGAINST
THE FCC'S DISCRETIONARY
AUTHORITY TO PURSUE THEIR
ORDERS? WELL, I WOULD START BY
SAYING THAT, BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE WITH PROVIDERS,
THERE'S GOING TO BE LEGAL
CHALLENGES TO THIS REGARDLESS,
THEY HAVE SUED BECAUSE THE CPUC
HAS SAID WE'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW
MUCH OF YOUR PROFIT IS GENERATED
FROM TELEPHONE SERVICE AND HOW
MUCH IS FROM BROADBAND SERVICE.
AND THEY SAID, WE DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE TO ANSWER THAT. SO
THAT'S A SEPARATE ISSUE, I THINK
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES HERE IS
THE FCC ORDER, HAS A LOT OF
SECTIONS WHERE THEY GO, THIS IS
OUR FRAMEWORK, BUT WE'RE
RESERVING THE RIGHT TO ADJUST
THAT AS WE NEED TO, BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW HOW THINGS ARE GOING
TO PLAY OUT. THAT'S WHY THEY
SAID THEY DIDN'T SAY, HEY,
LANDLORDS ARE COVERED ENTITIES.
THEY SAID WE'RE DECLINING TO
DECLARE THEY'RE NOT COVERED
ENTITIES AT THIS TIME, SO I
THINK IT'S MORE CHALLENGING AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT NECESSARILY AS MUCH
NIMBLENESS THERE. I ALSO I THINK
THIS IS RELATED. I APOLOGIZE IF
IT'S NOT, BUT ONE THING THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND IS THAT
WHEN PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA
DECIDE WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
BUILD OR UPGRADE THEIR NETWORKS,
THEY WON'T EVEN LOOK AT PLACES
WHERE THEY EXPECT TO MAKE LESS
THAN 20% RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
AND IT'S USUALLY MUCH HIGHER
THAN THAT. IT'S USUALLY 30% OR
ABOVE. SO THERE'S THESE
STATEMENTS THAT, OH, THERE'S
GOING TO BE ALL SORTS OF
HORRIBLE PROBLEMS, RIGHT I
UNDERSTAND. YEAH. SO I GET THE
OVERALL CONTEXT. I GUESS I'M
JUST TRYING TO SORT OF PINPOINT
THE ISSUE, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT
PROVIDED WE MOVE FORWARD TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SEEING THIS
THIS AFTERNOON IN JUDICIARY. SO
I GET THAT. ALSO, SOME OF THIS
IS BEYOND ENERGY. BUT I DID WANT
TO IF YOU WOULD INDULGE ME, MR.
CHAIR, JUST ASK THE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. JUST ABOUT
THIS IDEA OF LIKE INTEGRATING
THIS STANDARD OF PROOF. AND IF
THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE HOW THE
OPPOSITION VIEWS THIS STANDARD.
IF YOU ALL KNOW WHAT'S COMING,
YOUR WAY, I GET THAT YOUR
PRIMARY REQUEST IS ABOUT THE
SHIFTING TO A, AN INTENT
STANDARD, WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
GOING TO HAVE DIFFERENT
STANDARDS OF PROOF. BUT HOW DO
YOU ALL VIEW THE, THE, THE FCC
FRAMEWORK, WHICH YOU ALL
PARTICIPATED IN? COULD THAT BE
WORKABLE TO MIRROR HERE IN STATE
LAW? THANK YOU. SENATOR, FOR THE
QUESTION, I THINK AS YOU NOTED
IT, CHANGING THE OR ADDING IN
THE BURDEN SHIFTING FROM THE FCC
RULE, I OBVIOUSLY YOU'D HAVE TO
SEE LIKE, WHAT THE LANGUAGE IS
AND THAT KIND OF THING BECAUSE
IT SIGNIFICANTLY DOES NOT
ADDRESS OUR PRIMARY CONCERN
REGARDING, THE STANDARD OF
LIABILITY, BEING DISPARATE
IMPACT AND AVOIDING THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND A
FEW THINGS. I JUST WANTED TO
NOTE, IS THAT THE FCC IS A
REGULATORY PROCESS SO THEY CAN
SHIFT MORE EASILY WHEN THINGS
ARE NOT WORKING OR HAVING HARDER
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. AND
THIS FRAMEWORK, IT'S A
LITIGATION FRAMEWORK WHICH IS
NOT AS EASY TO SHIFT WHEN THINGS
ARE, NOT WORKING RIGHT. BUT ON
THE WHOLE, YOU'RE OKAY WITH THE
FCC FRAMEWORK AS IT STANDS NOW,
AS WE ARE, WE ARE WE ARE UNDER
LAWSUIT, RIGHT NOW, AGAINST THE
FCC REGARDING THAT, I SEE SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE CHALLENGING THAT
FRAMEWORK. SO UNDERSTOOD. ALL
RIGHT, I KNOW WE'LL BE SEEING
THIS FURTHER TODAY. I THINK
THAT'S A THREAD WORTH PULLING
DESPITE, THE OPPOSITION
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS THERE. SO I
JUST WOULD APPRECIATE THAT AS
EXTRA HOMEWORK. I THINK THAT
IT'S A LEGITIMATE THREAD TO
PULL. I THINK THE CHALLENGE IS
THAT, AND, AND CERTAINLY OPEN TO
CONSIDER CONTINUING TO DO THAT.
I THINK IT'S A THOUGHTFUL WAY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. I ACTUALLY
DO THINK IT VERY DIRECTLY
ADDRESSES, AND FURTHER DEFINES
DISPARATE IMPACT IN A WAY THAT
IS HELPFUL. SO I'M NOT CLEAR ON
THE OPPOSITION'S COMMENT, NOR AM
I CLEAR ON, QUITE FRANKLY, THE
MOVING, GOALPOSTS THAT I'VE BEEN
WE'VE BEEN SUBJECT TO IN THIS
BILL FOR THE LAST 18 MONTHS AS
WE'VE BEEN MOVING THIS BILL FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS, AS
WE'VE BEEN MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD, I JUST THINK INDUSTRY
NEEDS TO TAKE A PARTICULAR
POSITION. AND, AND THAT'S WHAT
IT'S GOING TO BE. SO I WILL
CONTINUE TO, IN GOOD FAITH, KIND
OF WORK ON THE POLICY ASPECTS OF
THIS, JUST DESPITE THAT. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? NO. OKAY. I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR, FOR
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE STAFF AND
MYSELF OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS OF TRYING TO, GET A BILL
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION ON. IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT WE'RE ALL VERY MUCH
CONCERNED WITH AND, I KNOW WE
HAVE A LOT OF CHALLENGES. I
APPRECIATE YOU WILLING TO TAKE
THE AMENDMENTS TO KEEP THE
DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD ON
THIS BILL. SO, ON THAT NOTE, IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE, I WOULD
LET YOU DO THAT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU, IN IN THE KIND OF
2009 TO 2000, 12 TIME FRAME
MEMORY ESCAPES, I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF CONSULTING WITH THE
FCC TO DEVELOP THE THEN OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN FOR THE
USE OF BROADBAND IN EDUCATION.
IT WAS BACK IN THE DAY WHEN WE
KIND OF SAID, THERE'S THIS THING
HAPPENING CALLED BROADBAND. HOW
IN THE WORLD DO WE MAKE SURE TO
BE ABLE TO USE IT FOR ITS MOST
EFFECTIVE USE IN ALL ASPECTS OF
IT? THE BROADBAND PLAN THAT THE
FCC MOVED FORWARD WITH? I WORKED
ON THE EDUCATION COMPONENT WAS
JUST ONE OF SEVERAL DIFFERENT
ASPECTS. THEY FOCUSED ON HOUSING
AND EMPLOYMENT, AND THE ULTIMATE
GOAL OF THE PLAN AT THAT TIME
AND THE INITIATIVE. AND SENATOR
BECKER WORKED ON AN ASPECT OF
THIS IS WAS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
INCREDIBLE ASSET WOULD BE USED
IN A WAY TO LIFT UP OUR
COMMUNITIES. THE REALITY RIGHT
NOW IS THAT WE HAVE COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE CONSISTENTLY SAYING TO
US, HEY, WE HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT,
WE ARE BEING LEFT OUT. WHEN
COVID HIT, IT WAS EVEN WORSE
BECAUSE WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED
WITH PEOPLE NOT HAVING THE
ABILITY TO ACCESS THROUGH THE
INTERNET, HEALTH CARE SERVICES,
THEIR EDUCATION, JOB,
EMPLOYMENT, ALL THE THINGS THAT
WE KNOW ARE NEEDED. INTERNET IS
NOW UNDENIABLY AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICE, AN ESSENTIAL ASSET THAT
EVERY COMMUNITY MEMBER SHOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO USE. WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS ENSURE THAT WHEN, DESPITE NÓ
MALICIOUSNESS, BUT DESPITE
PRACTICE, WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN LEFT
OUT. THIS BILL BY SIMPLY
OFFERING A DEFINITION AROUND
DIGITAL DISCRIMINATION OF ACCESS
ALLOWS THOSE COMMUNITIES A
REMEDY AND A VOICE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE AN ABILITY TO IMPACT THAT
FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES. WITH THAT
, I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO WE
DO HAVE A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THIS COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. AND
I'LL JUST STATE WHAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE. DELETE SECTION
TWO OF THE BILL. EXPAND THE
ENTITIES PROHIBITED FROM
ENGAGING IN DIGITAL
DISCRIMINATION TO INCLUDE
COVERED ENTITIES AS DEFINED BY
THE FCC ORDER. AND FINALLY, TO
CLARIFY THAT DIGITAL
DISCRIMINATION DOES NOT INCLUDE
POLICIES AND PRACTICES JUSTIFIED
BY LEGITIMATE BUSINESS
IMPEDIMENTS. IS THAT CORRECT,
SENATOR? ASSEMBLYMAN PONTE? THAT
IS CORRECT. OKAY. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AB 2239.
WE NEED A MOTION. WE NEED A
MOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. OKAY. IT'S DUE.
PASS TO BE AMENDED IN JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD,
I. DELHI. DELHI. NÓ. ASHBY ASHBY
I. BECKER BECKER. NOT VOTING.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I. DODD
DODD. NOT VOTING. DURAZO. DURAZO
I. EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROVE. LIMON MIN.
MIN. NOT VOTING. NEUMANN NEUMANN
I RUBIO. CIERTO. CIERTO. NØ
SKINNER. SKINNER I STERN. STERN.
I WILK. WILK. NÓ 9 TO 3 AND
NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE. THAT'S
CURRENTLY 9 TO 3. YOU NEED ONE
MORE VOTE TO GET OUT. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER? WAS THAT OUR
LAST BILL? OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO START AT THE TOP
OF THE ROLL, AND, THE FILE I
SHOULD SAY, AND GO THROUGH THE
ROLL, OKAY. YES STARTING WITH
FILE ITEM ONE AB 551. WE NEED A
MOTION RIGHT HERE. MOTION BY
SENATOR DALLI. WE HAVE A, DO
PASS, AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD I
BRADFORD I DALLY, I DALLY I
ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER. YES BECKER
I CABALLERO CABALLERO I DODD
DODD I DURAZZO. DURAZZO I EGGMAN
. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
GROVE. LIMÓN. MIN MIN I NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I RUBIO. CIERTO CIERTO I
SKINNER. SKINNER I STERN, STERN.
I WILK. WILK I 15 TO 0 I.
CURRENT VOTES 15 TO 0. EVERYONE
UP OR WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN ON THAT. WE HAVE
ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO
LEAVE THAT OPEN. ALL RIGHT. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. NUMBER
THREE 1533. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR DALLI. WE HAVE A DO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO, SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB 1533 CONSENT ITEM. CONSENT
ITEM. YEAH. THAT WAS CONSENT.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I DALLI.
DALLI I ASHBY. ASHBY I BECKER.
BECKER I CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
DODD. DODD I. DURAZZO. DURAZZO I
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROVE. LIMÓN. ON THE
LIMÓN I MIN MIN I NEWMAN. NEWMAN
I RUBIO. CIERTO CIERTO I
SKINNER. SKINNER I STERN, STERN.
I WILK WILK I CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GROVE. RUBIO CONSENT.
THAT'S CONSENT. SENATOR RUBIO.
RUBIO I SO 17 TO 0. JUST 17
ZERO. WE'RE MISSING ONE MEMBER
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT NOW MOVING
ON TO ITEM FOUR AB 2368 BY
PETRIE-NORRIS. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR DALLI. WE HAVE Dð
PASSES AMENDED TO SUBMIT SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB 2368
PETRIE-NORRIS BRADFORD. BRADFORD
I DALLI. DALLI I ASHBY. ASHBY I
BECKER. BECKER I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I DODD. DODD I.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
GROVE. LIMÓN LIMÓN I MIN MIN I
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I RUBIO. RUBIO I
CIERTO CIERTO I SKINNER. SKINNER
I STERN, STERN I WILK WILK I 17
TO 0. THAT MEASURES OUT 17 ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL MOVE ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM FIVE AB 2006 72
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
MOTION. OH, DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
EGGMAN, AGAIN. DO PASS IS A
MINUTE TO SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SECRETARY, CALL
THE ROLL. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I
DELI, DELI. NOT VOTING. ASHBY
ASHBY I BECKER. BECKER I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I DODD.
DODD I DURAZZO. DURAZZO I
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROVE. LIMÓN LIMÓN I
MIN MIN I NEWMAN. NEWMAN I RUBIO
. RUBIO I CIERTO CIERTO. NOT
VOTING. SKINNER. SKINNER I STERN
, STERN I WILK WILK I 15 TO 0.
CURRAN. VOTES 15 ZERO. WE'LL
LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN NOW MOVING
ON TO ITEM SIX AB 1588 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON. WE HAVE
A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. WE
STILL NEED A MOTION. SHE TOOK
AMENDS. SHE TOOK THE MEN. IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR EGGMAN.
THE AMENDMENTS JUST SENATOR
EGGMAN. SENATOR, SENATOR, JUST
FOR CLARITY, SHE'LL BE TAKING
THEM, IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
RIGHT OR DID SHE? NO. SHE TOOK A
MIRROR. YEAH, THINKING ABOUT
ANOTHER BILL. SO SHE TOOK A
MIRROR. YEAH. ALL RIGHT. YOU CAN
CALL THE ROLL, AB 1588 BY WILSON
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I DALLY,
DALLY NØ ASHBY. ASHBY I BECKER.
BECKER I CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
DODD. DODD I DURAZZO. DURAZZO I
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROVE. LIMÓN LIMON. I
MEAN MIN I NEWMAN. NEWMAN I
RUBIO RUBIO I CIERTO. CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER STERN STERN STERN I
SKINNER I WILK NÓ WILK. NO 14 TO
3. CURRENT VOTES 14 TO 3. WE'LL
LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NOW I'LL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB 1912 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO. SO
MOVED. WE GOT A MOTION BY
SENATOR DALLI. WE HAVE DUE
PASSES AMENDED TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD I
BRADFORD. I DALLI. DALLI I ASHBY
. ASHBY I BECKER. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I DODD. DODD I DURAZZO
I DURAZZO I. EGGMAN EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I GROVE.
LIMÓN. LIMÓN I MIN MIN I NEWMAN
NEWMAN I RUBIO. RUBIO I CIERTO.
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER. SKINNER I
STERN. WILK I WILK I 14 TO 1.
TÍNH ZERO. THAT MEASURES OUT.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
2054 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER.
CAN WE HAVE DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS? DO I HAVE A
MOTION MOVE. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DODD, SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB 2054 BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I. DALLI ASHBY I ASHBY
I BECKER. BECKER I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I DODD. DODD I DURAZO.
DURAZO I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I GROVE.
LIMÓN LIMÓN I MIN MIN I NEWMAN
NEWMAN I RUBIO RUBIO I CIERTO
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER. SKINNER I
STERN, STERN. I WILK WILK NÓ 14
TO 2. 14 TO 2. THAT MEASURES OUT
NOW. MEMBERS WILL MOVE IN TO
FILE ITEM NINE. WE HAVE A
MOTION. WE HAVE LIFTING THE CALL
. FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. 2239 BONTA
DO PASS TO BE AMENDED IN
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. CURRENT
VOTE NINE THREE. CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING NO.
GROVE LIMON LIMÓN. AYE RUBIO.
TEN THREE. TEN THREE. THAT
MEASURES OUT. WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS IF
THEY CHOOSE TO ADD ON. NOW FOR
ITEM TEN. SORIA 2661. IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR DALLI. WE HAVE
DO PASS TO THE FLOOR. SECRETARY
MAY CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I DALLI. DALLI. AYE
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER BECKER
I CABALLERO. CABALLERO I DODD.
DODD I. DURAZZO. DURAZZO I.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROVE. LEMON LEMON I
MIN MIN I NEWMAN. NEWMAN I RUBIO
RUBIO I CIERTO CIERTO I SKINNER.
SKINNER I STERN, STERN I WILK.
WILK I 17 TO 0 17 ZERO. WILL
LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
ITEM NINE. WE JUST SAID 1111 NØ.
IT'S NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM 11.
I WAS TEN. THAT WAS TEN. NOW
FILE 11 AB 2666 BY WARNER. WE
HAVE A DO PASS IS A MINUTE TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A MOTION. MOVE THE BILL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. SECRETARY MAY CALL
THE ROLL AB 2666. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I DEL DALLY NÓ ASHBY.
ASHBY I BECKER. BECKER I
CABALLERO. CAVIAR. I DODD I DODD
I DURAZZO. DURAZZO. I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
GROVE. LEMON, LEMON I MIN MIN I
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I RUBIO RUBIO I
CIERTO. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER.
SKINNER I STERN, STERN. I WILK
WILK I 15 TWO. CURRENT VOTES 15
TWO. WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 12 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADIS AB 2847. WE
NEED A MOTION. STILL SEEKING A
MOTION ON THIS ONE. I'M SORRY.
SO MOVED. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR BECKER. PLEASE CALL Dð.
PASSES A MINUTE TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS, AB
2847 BRADFORD. BRADFORD I.
DALLI. DALLI, NO. ASHBY ASHBY I
BECKER. BECKER I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I DODD. DODD I
DURAZZO. DURAZZO I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
GROVE. LEMON LIMÓN I MIN. MIN I
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I RUBIO. RUBIO I
CIERTO CIERTO. NO. SKINNER.
SKINNER I STERN, STERN. I WILK.
WILK I 15 TWO 1515 215 TWO. THAT
MEASURES OUT. WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 13 AB 3111 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON.
PLEASE. WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
MOTION ON THIS, FOLKS. MOVED BY
WILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
WILK 3111 DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. YOU CAN CALL THE
ROLL BRADFORD. BRADFORD I DELHI
DELHI I ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER.
BECKER I CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
DODD. DODD I DURAZZO. DURAZZO I
EGGMAN. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
GROVE. LIMÓN LIMÓN I MIN MIN I
NEWMAN. THAT WAS AN I. YES.
OKAY. SORRY. YES. THERE WAS NONE
I TO I NEWMAN, I RUBIO RUBIO I
CIERTO SKINNER. OH THANK YOU
SKINNER I STERN STERN NOT VOTING
WILK WILK I.
YES. WHAT'S OUR COUNT. 14 ZERO.
14 ZERO. THAT MEASURE OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR. ALL RIGHT. NOW
MOVING ON. FILE ITEM 14 BY
CALDERON AGAIN. AB 3263. WE NEED
A MOTION WILK MOTION BY SENATOR
WILK. WE HAVE A DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SECRETARY, YOU
CAN CALL THE ROLL BRADFORD I
BRADFORD I DALLI. DALLI. NO.
ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER. BECKER I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I DODD.
DODD I. DURAZZO. DURAZZO I
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I. GROVE. GROVE NO.
LEMON. LEMON I MIN. MIN NO
NEWMAN I NEWMAN I RUBIO. RUBIO I
CIERTO. SKINNER SKINNER. NOT
VOTING. STERN STERN I WILK. WILK
I 13 TO 313 THREE. THAT MEASURES
OUT. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
1632 56 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN. WE NEED A MOTION. IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR LEMON. WE
HAVE A DO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. YOU CAN CALL THE
ROLL. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I
DALLY DALLY I ASHBY ASHBY I
BECKER. BECKER I CABALLERO
CABALLERO I DODD DODD I DURAZZO.
DURAZZO I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I GROVE.
LIMÓN LEMON I MIN MIN I NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I RUBIO RUBIO RUBIO I
CIERTO. SKINNER. SKINNER I
STERN, STERN I WILK WILK I GROVE
I IS THIS 32 6056 256. I WANT TO
CHANGE MY VOTE ON CALDERON 32. I
GO BACK TO 63. OKAY. HOLD ON, SO
DO YOU WANT TO DO YOU WANT TO
ANNOUNCE THIS VOTE? DO YOU WANT
TO DO YOU WANT TO ANNOUNCE THE
VOTE ON 3256 THAT WE JUST TOOK
THE VOTE ON? YES. CAN YOU
ANNOUNCE THE VOTE ON 30, 17 TO
0, 17 TO 0. OKAY. AND THEN,
DOLLY, WHICH ONE? 3263. 32. 63.
YOU VOTED NO. I DIDN'T KNOW NO
TO I AB 3263 CALDERON DALLY NO
TO I TO I WITH THE AMENDMENTS
GROVE NO TO I. OKAY. 15 TO 1. 15
TO 1 THAT MEASURES IS THAT ARE
WE FINISHED WITH THAT. COME AND
CLOSE IT. I THINK SO, YES, YES,
WE CAN CLOSE THE ROLL ON THAT.
SO WE HAVE TO WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE FILE ONE
MORE TIME FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAT ON AM I CORRECT? WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
ONE AB 551. SO MEMBERS WE'RE
TRYING TO GO THROUGH THESE. GET
THESE ABSENT MEMBERS OUT HERE AB
551 DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 15
ZERO GROVE I'M SORRY 551 BENNETT
GROVE I LEMON LEMON I RUBIO
RUBIO I. 18 TO 0 18 ZERO THAT
MEASURES OUT NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE 1533 THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AB 1533 CURRENT
VOTE 17 ZERO GROVE GROVE I 18
ZERO 18 ZERO 18 ZERO THAT
MEASURES OUT CONSENT CALENDARS
OUT NOW. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FOR AB 2368. CURRENT VOTE 17
ZERO GROVE GROVE I 18 ZERO 18
ZERO. THAT MEASURES OUT NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM FIVE AB 2672.
CURRENT VOTE 15 ZERO. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. GROVE. NOT VOTING.
GROVE. NOT VOTING. 15 ZERO 15.
ZERO. THAT MEASURES OUT. AND NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM SIX 1588.
CURRENT VOTE 14 TO 3. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. GROVE 15 GROVE. NO. 14 TO 4.
14 TO 4. THAT MEASURES OUT NOW.
MOVING ON TO ITEM SEVEN AB 1912.
CURRENT VOTE 14 ONE. CHAIR. VICE
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. BECKER GROVE.
GROVE I STERN VOTING 15 ONE. 15
ONE THAT MEASURES OUT AND CLOSE
THE ROLL. NOW TO AB 2054.
FOLLOWING FIVE AND FILE ITEM
EIGHT AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN.
CURRENT VOTE 14 TWO CHAIR VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
GROVE I GROVE I. 15 TO 215 TWO.
THAT MEASURES OUT OR CLOSE. ROLL
ON THAT. WE'RE ON NINE RIGHT?
YES ALL RIGHT AB 2239 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CURRENT
VOTE TEN THREE. CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING NO.
GROVE. GROVE. NO RUBIO. RUBIO
AYE. 11 TO 4. 11 TO 4. THAT
MEASURES. OUT OR CLOSE. ROLL NOW
FOLLOWING ITEM TEN AB 2661.
CURRENT VOTE 17 ZERO GROVE.
GROVE. I 18 ZERO 18 ZERO. THAT
MEASURES OUT. ROLES CLOSED
FOLLOWING 11 AB 2666. CURRENT
VOTE 15 TWO. CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
VICE CHAIR. VOTING NO. GROVE.
GROVE. NO 15 315 THREE. THAT
MEASURES OUT. ROLL. CLOSE THE
ROLL. FILE. I'M 12 2847. CURRENT
VOTE 15 TWO. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. GROVE.
PARDON ME. I'M SORRY. 2847
ADAMS. CHAIR. VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. 15 TWO GROVE.
NO. 15 315 THREE MEASURES OUT
THE ROLES CLOSED. NEXT UP FOR
ITEM 1331 11 CURRENT VOTE 14
ZERO. EGGMAN GROVE. CIERTO. 14
ZERO 14 ZERO. CLOSE THE ROLL
THAT MEASURES OUT. NEXT UP, AB
FILE ITEM 14 AB 3263. CURRENT
VOTE 15 ONE. CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SATO AND
THAT'S IT. 15 ONE 1515 ONE THAT
MEASURES OUT AND, I CHANGED MY
VOTE TO AYE RIGHT AFTER THE
AMENDMENTS OR NOT. YOU DID ON
20, 32, 63. YES. YOU ARE AN AYE.
OKAY. BECAUSE THE AMENDMENTS.
OKAY. THANK YOU MA'AM. AND OUR
LAST ITEM IS FILE ITEM 1632 56.
AM I CORRECT? YES. CURRENT VOTE
17 ZERO. CIERTO. GOOD JOB, GOOD
JOB. ALL RIGHT. 17 ZERO 17 ZERO.
THAT MEASURES OUT CLOSED RO
SENATOR DAHLE. I JUST LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
THE HARD WORKING STAFF FOR THE
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND
COMMUNICATIONS, BEEN HERE AT THE
TIME WHOLE TIME AS VICE CHAIR
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE SENATE.
AND I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
STAFF. I THINK THIS IS OUR LAST,
HEARING, AND IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU ALL.
ALSO, JUST LIKE TO SAY IT'S BEEN
A PLEASURE TO WORK WITH OUR
CHAIRMAN, WAS MY SEATMATE WHEN I
FIRST CAME IN, AND, IT'S BEEN AN
HONOR TO WORK ALONGSIDE SOMEBODY
THAT REALLY UNDERSTANDS THE
ISSUES AND WORKS HARD TO BRING
ALL THE PUBLIC IN AND DO THE
RIGHT THING. SOMETIMES THAT'S
HARD TO SAY, BUT AS A GOOD
FRIEND, I APPRECIATE BEING YOUR
VICE CHAIR AND WORKING ALONGSIDE
YOU. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DALLI. AND I TOO JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE HARD
WORKING STAFF FOR A VERY
CHALLENGING YEAR. BUT YOU KNOW,
WE GOT THROUGH IT. AND DESPITE
MANY TIMES OUR DIFFERENCES, WE
FOUND A WAY TO MAKE A WAY FOR
POLICY THAT WE FEEL WILL HAVE A
GREAT IMPACT. SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU ALSO TO MY
COLLEAGUE FOR BEING A SOUND VICE
CHAIR AND WILLING TO TAKE THE
GAVEL WHENEVER, YOU KNOW, I HAD
TO RUN TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE AND
I HOPE THIS IS NOT OUR LAST
GATHERING, BUT IF NOT, WE JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE EVERYBODY WHO
HAS DONE SO MUCH TO KEEP US ON
TRACK AND KEEP THE TRAINS
MOVING. SO, THAT CONCLUDES ALL
OF OUR BUSINESS FOR THIS
HEARING. AND I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY, UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS IS NOW ADJOURNED.